Hello everybody!
Oh shit, left side dokey here.
We're going to be back with Mouse PI for hire.
Today's going to be a long stream because this is a very
long game.
Surprisingly, I think I'm not even halfway yet, apparently.
So we're going to see how far we can go today.
Mouse PI for hire.
And also if I remember any of the controls, because it has
been, if it's more than two days, I do not because there's
so many type of different games to play all right so there's
the dash all right i think i got it guys i think it's in my
brain all right left side joki is back all right vivian so
what exactly did you do at tensels to get your glimmers to
hide someone's like all you need is kick but i don't even
remember how to kick please i left on my own terms nose high
tail swaying single boot print on my rear.
Well, by the way, there must have been a reason.
Oh, I don't know.
Ridiculous overtime, zero artistic integrity, the occasional
wandering hand.
Oh, a paycheck so thin I could roll a cheese stick with it.
That's Hollywood for ya, baby.
Surely those ain't the only reasons, right?
Sounds like you got a soft spot for the place.
No pre-duck, I mean, I don't really... There hasn't been
many updates since the live stream till now.
Cancels wasn't just a job.
It was an experience, a lifestyle.
You didn't just make movies.
You took life by the handful, gave it a good shake, and
spilled every last drop onto the screen.
You know what I did right after that stream?
I ate dinner, and then I went to bed.
So there's no updates whatsoever here today.
They're just kind of gamed.
So, you partied too hard and got yourself in trouble.
I partied just enough.
Though, in hindsight, my just enough might have been a
little much for the wussies.
But without those parties, I'd never have met half the
dazzling souls I did.
I'd never have met- I'm pretty sure the moths did.
I've not seen the moth lying anywhere.
Moths have a very short lifespan.
Some moths are just born to fuck and then die.
They don't even have mouths to digest, uh, like the wild,
the, the captivity moths.
I know, like, silkworms.
Silkworms, they don't even have mouths.
They are just born, they let out the thermodes, and then
they go crazy, and then they die.
Because they starve to death.
Because they don't have mouths.
I think that's fucking crazy.
Like, born without a mouth.
Like, they were, uh, what is it called?
They were selected breeding so hard that they just don't
have mouths anymore.
Isn't that awesome?
No need to sustain themselves.
They just go at it and then starve to death.
What a way to go.
Not even a hard attack because some mice, they die from
heart attacks from banging too hard.
Male mice, some male mice speak.
They just die after after fucking too much And then get a
heart attack But for mobs they bang as much as they want And
then they just starve to death Just for the love of the game
Okay F is the kick Okay Evolution said it worked the best So
check mate That's the life So grab a rod and catch one Oh,
but not just any fish a special fish for a special fish dish
Oh, you're not asking for fish sticks, are you really Jack?
That's a low blow No fish sticks.
No.
I need Hmm.
I think it's called marinated herring Tanned or red herring
some old world delicacy not exactly easy on the senses are
here.
Oh Yes, I've only hard stories, Jack, but yes, be careful
with this one, alright?
Alright, I just gotta find, grab some, search Wallop Bay for
Canherin.
Alright, if they require, okay, nice.
I don't have to, um, I don't have to backtrack.
Okay, I was like, if I'm backtracking, you're never getting
your fish, sir.
Uh, Patra said, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
If I don't have a mouth, I'll scream with my pores, my
bones, with my very being, see, thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank Thank you.
Danny, Danny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, please.
As the boomer, you obliterated on stage, I beg you, never
bring out sexy Doki again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's on you.
You didn't defeat sexy Doki.
So now sexy Doki is here forever.
Didn't ignite a flame in your heart to beat sexy Doki even
more?
Clearly it wasn't enough.
Sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, the game doesn't let you backtrack good.
I hate backtracking.
I just want to gas, gas, gas.
Did I already upgrade everything?
I gotta check.
Alright.
Let me make sure.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Oh, I was saving up.
Yeah, I needed one more.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, off to the next level.
cheese there we go all right the windmill where's wallabay
though okay that's wallabay i know i have more missions for
wallabay but i want to know the secrets all right got my
morning martini ready to drink and drive like the good old
days yeah i do a little loop to loop not because i'm because
that's what they do back in the day.
Crooked trees, crooked roads, and crooked stairs.
Welcome to Kurdsville.
Kurdsville.
Alright, let's save real quick.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remember to beat the crap out of the shark and fat harbor.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ooh, nice.
I knew.
I thought it was weird that there was some money in that
corner.
How do I get up?
way wait no i came up from this way oh no i forgot it's all
black and white it's been so long i've been looking at
colors how do i get out of here okay oh my god double jump
wait guys remember when i said it if i don't play a game in
more than two days i forget all the controls all sleepy and
hollow just the way I pictured it oh it's Transylvania okay
I forgot I had double jump all right beware I know I have
like other abilities too well there's uh the old shaman oh
the James gun oh sorry turn around and leave yeah this ain't
no place for a city mouse bad spirits Juju's Oh Sins Unknown
forces I'm looking for the family home of Miles Curd That
the big one overlooked in the village And why is that, huh?
You don't know Are you gonna find Batman?
I'm sorry, Batmouse?
What you want with the likes of Curds?
I'm on a case Helplessly trying to save Oh, it's Mouse
Louisiana String Cheese Oh, my boy Mouseyanna Then you bet
so long Oh, to this little thing.
And don't sell yourself short, lady.
You got some muscle for it.
Ain't what I meant, she said.
Take this greedy.
Keeps me there, right?
Beashell.
Might say that...
Oh my god, all I can think about is...
Uh, thanks.
Gavin never falls!
That's all I can think about, Yringer.
Oh my god, it's been so long since I've played this game.
Oh my god, wait, there's dogs!
Oh shit, this is a Pluto situation.
That's a Pluto goofy situation right now.
Oops, I got reloaded.
Wait, does that mean real mice also exist in this world?
If they have dogs?
guys don't worry don't worry it's cartoon logic he's not
dead he's just missing his head guys not a bad person
all right i gotta remember how to shoot my gun okay i
remember the tommy gun was really good sorry the james gun
oh oh you look at the remember use both barrels oh it's a
double barrel shotgun
Okay, that means more damage.
Two barrels, more than one, equals more damage.
I feel like I still should use the James gun, though.
He'll die eventually, right?
Oh, shit, dog!
Who's shooting me?
I mean, oh, there he is.
I was like, where are they?
Oh, no, not the babies.
Not the babies.
Okay, this would be a good time to use it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, nice.
It has, like, a flame attack.
Okay.
I will try the double barrel.
I'm sure there's a nice rash.
Oh, my God.
One HP.
Okay, we gotta get...
Oh, geez.
Oh, nice.
We got blueprint.
That's good.
All right, this is where we have to go.
So let's go grab all the loot.
That's what tried my head.
I was like, what do all these guns do again?
It's been so long.
It's been two days.
That might as well be 80 years.
You know, that one character we met in slot and half just
chilling in the room and talk.
Yeah, I was going to say, yeah, how does a dog die?
Like, there's no way.
That dog is so fine.
He's alright.
If a lady can survive being sawed in half, a dog can live
without a head.
Or even the rats too.
We just gotta find the head.
Everything is fine.
As long as we are able to re- we can re-attach.
Yeah, he's just sleeping.
Guys, we can re-attach the head.
He's gotta apply some ointment on him.
Oh, I can't headshot him because he's wearing a mask.
I just noticed that.
There you go.
Oh, shit, sniper!
Where is he?
Where the fuck is that sniper?
Oh, that hit me, actually.
There you go.
Can't hurt me no more.
Why would there be a canister here?
Is there something I can throw?
Hmm.
There's something here that's breakable?
That's totally not a wall?
Oh.
I guess not.
I just got this for free.
Oh, maybe it was for the sniper.
Maybe.
I was gonna say, where's the totally not a wall wall?
All right.
We'll keep using the James gun.
I think the James gun is, like, super strong.
No, I need to find a key for that lock.
I think it's a shortcut or something over there.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, nice save.
It's always a good sign.
Great.
A bunch of zealots loaded with guns,
That's fine.
You know what?
I'm tired of this.
Give me your life savings right now.
Alright, there's the caretaker.
You're forgetting there's fall damage in this game.
I'm here to...
Excuse me, I'm here to play video games to escape from
reality.
Why give me fall damage?
Oh, there's too many players.
places to go.
Alright.
There's somewhere.
This door is openable.
It's like in Scooby-Doo where you can tell when an item is
interactable.
I know I can open this door so I look.
I literally see it.
I see the key.
I have arms.
Why can't I just open the door?
Okay.
The windows are all locked up.
Like, what's the point of having fingers if I can't open a
goddamn door?
Alright, not here, I guess.
Definitely need HP, though.
Okay, bosses, enemies are gonna come up from here.
Someone's gonna come up from here, too.
Okay, nope.
This is where I...
Oh, nice money.
Okay, I don't need heals.
I'm gonna grab ammo real quick.
Alright, we have to speak to the caretaker now, wherever he
is.
I already already lost.
No entries.
Ah, the church.
That rings a bell.
Okay.
That's a weird thing to talk about.
Just like it's telling me to do something.
I don't see no bell.
Wait.
This house is openable.
Oh, it's a block pick right here.
Alright, nice.
Knock, knock.
It's not breaking or entering if there's nobody inside.
Fuck, okay.
I like that.
Tells me, like, there's something that's gonna be like
ooga-booga-booga.
Oh, no, it's just...
Yeah.
It's just money.
Alright, now I'll talk to him.
I got all the money.
Evening, sir.
The names...
Don't care.
No visitors.
But see, uh, I'm a P.I.
and gumshoes stained carpets no gumshoes scram how about a
little tune on the world's tiniest violin more stubborn than
my ex-wives wives holy i can tell why you're divorced but
first i need to get rid of that grumpy obstacle how care for
a little fortune telling shell how did you get here did you
get here i'll pass in the crystal balls but i'm all ears for
ideas on bypassing old jerks oh that's easy baby what scales
a deadbeat husband more than a hungry gator xy's
responsibilities close i do it it's always xy's i'm not sure
i follow that okay never trust the street he got Now, find
three wedding rings from his ex's shell.
Man sees him.
He gave like a soggy croak.
Come.
At this point, you should stop marrying.
Just be a player.
Oh, shit.
Oh, coot.
Lila gagger.
Three rings.
Sure.
What could possibly go wrong?
Oh, shit.
Oh, there they are.
Let's grab.
That's not what I wanted to use.
That was it?
Nope.
Oh, hey.
There is a bell.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Where did you come from?
I was gonna say, at this point, it's just, like, financially
irresponsible to keep marrying.
Unless you get a prenup.
Like, the amount of 50-50s?
Alright.
Let's go here.
Jeez.
Okay, you can headshot.
I thought because he was wearing a helmet, it wouldn't work.
Second place for Betty Lynch.
For the unparalleled ability, erase herself from her head
completely and replace it fully with the acting purpose.
A rickety frame holds an award for a school acting contest.
It reads, for Betty Lynch.
Oh, is this where she lives?
Well, well, well.
It's their own stomping grounds.
all right oh fuck nice I'm glad that he just stood still
wait she's dead excuse for a husband I'll show him a
reconcilable differences you know losing that wedding ring
might help you let go the boys builds character say how
about a revenge dinner first help me cut that bum down to
size and who knows maybe something more god forbid i get
cranky when i'm stuffed damn even when it goes she's like on
my own damn she's not giving up
what's he gonna do you're like 20 miles away with a shotgun
i learned my lesson there all right peekaboo oh peekaboo
Even in death, there's still time to Riz.
You think he's gonna learn?
There you go.
No, he's never gonna learn.
Damn, he fucking tanked that shit.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I know this gun is OP.
This gun is way too strong.
It's not even matched out yet.
This opens on the other side.
I need more James gun ammo real quick.
I'm pretty sure I don't have a license for any of these
guns.
I like, or like only one of these guns, because I found it
on the ground.
Half of them I found it on the ground.
The good old days.
What?
Who shot me?
God, you never, you'll never expect the one in the sky.
The good old days when you don't need a license.
Oh, you know what?
Oh, fuck, never mind.
I'll just shoot your eye.
Yeah, I don't need that.
Yeah, when you don't need a gun for acid...
Well, technically you don't need a license for acid.
In general.
Okay.
I know in some places you can just...
I feel like, you know...
It's not very safe, but you can order acid online.
For legal reasons.
This is for educational purposes.
Not that I'm telling you guys to order acid on the internet.
But...
But in some places, you can order acid on the internet.
The power's back.
Oh, more cheese.
Oh, is 10 the max?
I think it is.
We're side, exactly.
I mean, that's the whole purpose, though, isn't it?
Chemistry and all that?
Boy, the hoops I jump through just to get a thing.
Oh, my gosh, just one guy.
Oh, yeah, that's how they burn the...
That's how they get rid of bodies in Breaking Bad.
You're right.
I'll take that.
I don't think I need it, but I'll take it.
Yeah, I feel like it might need to be better regulated
somehow.
Maybe that acid needs to be better regulated.
Just a little maybe.
I'll burn the dev sooner or later.
See I watched one episode of Breaking Bad, so I know that.
Oh, shit, he's still here!
Okay, I thought he would be dead by now.
Oh, I'm ran out of ammo.
I just might have to use acid.
Acid always works.
I'll eventually put...
Yep, there we go.
Acid ain't the...
Oh, how do you know that?
Huh?
Well, how do you know there's more than one way?
To the god, I was like...
Law, acid isn't the only way.
The FBI is listening now.
John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, I already ordered my industrial quantity of
hydrochloric acid.
BSU sends the glory to the turkey bird empire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How the fuck am I supposed to go?
I remember I saw like a little magnifying glass here.
For whom the bell toes?
Have one ring.
That's it.
Would you be scared of one XY?
This is like this way.
It says no entry.
Where is he leading me?
What?
Oh no.
I'm lost.
Everything is black and white.
I got everything here.
Where am I supposed to go?
Lolly, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Told us about the pigs before.
Oh yeah, what's my guidance button?
It's been so long since I looked for clues, gang.
Oh.
I'm gonna have to look at the controls.
It's actually been too long.
Controllers.
Inventory.
Oh, there you go.
Detective Brush M.
Alright.
Where's my yellow paint?
Okay, I do have to go this way.
Oh, it was...
Oh, back in the tunnels.
Okay, get the cheese pump running.
Oh, I thought that was like...
That's what the key was for.
Ooh, a secret tunnel!
And didn't even know I was rhyming those words.
Oh my god, he's just a natural.
Secret tunnel!
There's a save.
Oh.
Oops.
There you go.
Yay, more money.
All right, we go this way.
Do I have ammo?
I do.
Nice.
Honestly, I think I could just use James gun throughout all
of it.
Oh.
Oh, so it wasn't divorced.
Sounds like your husband is around.
real downer why not let go of that ring and give him an
earful huh you know what i might just do that wait guys i
have a feeling that the ex-husband might be a murderer but
i'm not sure yeah i need one more clue to be absolutely sure
i might need one more clue to figure it out be my final
clue.
Blue schedule.
We can't do.
Oh, shit.
Murdered on their wedding?
I think you are reaching.
Oh, my God.
I wonder who killed her.
Oh, shit.
Okay, at least they're like sort of one shot.
Oh, my God.
Now there's flaming fucking scholars.
Now we're dooming now.
Oh, it's Luigi rules!
Ow.
That's fine.
Oh, oh, where'd she go?
Alright, it's Luigi rules.
We just gotta use the flashlight.
These guys are annoying though.
I think the ghosts are the the most annoying ones.
The floating headscarves.
Here she go.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, do I break it?
Oh, I have to break it.
Yeah, I have to break the bubble.
Alright, get over here.
Look into the light.
Come into the light, woman!
Move on!
There's plenty of men in heaven!
You can even date Leonardo the mouse!
Imagine that!
The power of light compels you!
I figured I should just kick it.
Where did she go?
I don't think she's going to heaven.
Her only sin was just trying to find love.
And marrying the guy whose wife, whose two wives
mysteriously disappear.
Okay, that's actually on her.
Like, she's like, oh, I wonder what happened to your two
other wives.
Surely nothing bad happened to her.
Not gonna lie, that was sort of, like, on her.
Okay.
Like, was that not suspicious as all women?
For real.
It's like, oh, just some little accidents.
Don't worry.
It'll be different this time.
It's not a sin to marry a murderer.
Don't keep burying.
I gotta reload.
Oh, that's not the right one.
There she is.
like I can fix him don't worry I won't be the this will be
the one time he won't murder a wife it'll be different this
time oh it's nice that the skull doesn't come over here
there you go flashy flash yay patch your eyes too thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you How big of do you
know, watch true crime, dokey?
It's very weird that all of this man's wives just
mysteriously disappeared.
Oh, got the secret.
Is there anything in that secret?
No, it was just ammo.
Couldn't be a coincidence.
It's, it's, guys, correlation does not equal causation.
Maybe she thought the wives just didn't like him and just
ran away.
You really ain't him, huh?
Oh, that filthy cauldron.
Send in someone else to do with dirty work.
I'll tan his hide myself.
Well, I'd rather not miss that.
Oh, my God, cat fight.
We can't miss that.
He's so right.
We're gonna get ghost catfut.
I live again.
I wasn't.
I love you all.
No, of course, Felicia.
You're my favorite.
No, but...
Rest in peace, caretaker.
Look at that.
Now he has three wives.
Three for one special.
What a dream.
He's got everything.
he's ever won in.
In case of emergency, please do not dig up.
He's so... Guys, look at that.
He has his own harem now.
He got the harem ending.
You there?
What's all that ruckus down in the hall?
Uh, ruckus?
Uh, probably nothing.
Uh, but I'll take a look.
Just to be safe.
Anyway, open the door.
It's definitely your uncle.
Who's that to help?
Some long-long.
Thank God we didn't teach the child about stranger danger.
Yeah, I'm running out of bullets.
I'm going to start using acid.
All right, I need more James gun ammo.
All right, we'll grab this book.
Uh, something for a sharp nose detective.
like me.
What's this?
Oh, it's a photo.
Oh, that's the...
That's the kid.
A big one here, Millie, the half-shrue!
Oh, that's why they locked her up.
They mixed interspecies.
Alone in a Kurd's mansion is, in truth, his illegitimate
daughter.
An old flaky photo shows Miles' courage of a little girl
beside him.
Both look one.
wildly uncomfortable somehow.
This discomfort makes Kurt seem just a little bit tense and
you're remembered.
Oh my god.
Most peculiar.
Interspecies relations in 1930s?
How how could this be?
Is that even possible?
Half blood.
Half shrew.
Disgust.
A dossier on a strange cult that emerged in Maasburg Seems
the big mouse party is surveillance seeing these crazy
Files, papers, and pictures All stuffed into one sneak
folder Contains dossiers on multiple cult members And
outlines BMP's thinly filled planet Poke around some secret
show So the BMP's officials are keeping an eye on the cult
member What's there anymore?
What are they looking for?
I think...
Oh shit, I didn't even see the little guy.
Half... I can't believe it.
In this day and age, we...
Half...
I can't believe I live to see it.
A half-true, half-mouse breed.
I didn't even think it was possible.
All right, nice.
Then we need the armor, too.
Oh, nice.
Blueprint.
Okay, that can finally upgrade my James gun.
Cool painting.
Oh, there was a anvil here.
Oh.
Yeah, I need the flashlight.
I can't see.
Ah!
No!
Fuck, okay.
All right.
Flashbang.
Oh, my God.
It's so bright.
actually squinting right now that is way that is like some
fucking strongest flashlight in the world type shit oh oh my
god they actually locked her up in the attic of
course they actually locked her up like in the attic picking
up phones in weird places wasn't really my game but this one
was asking for it Hello?
Buddy Lynch is scratching the picture.
And the cheese curds have chrono.
Is that Vivian?
This is the operator.
There's been a murder at the secret show.
Oh!
Miles Curd is dead.
I repeat, Miles Curd is dead.
Miles Curd?
Oh no, she's an orphan now!
Wait, no, we can still find her mom, her shrew mom.
Miles Kurt is dead.
How could this be?
I literally saw him.
Five days ago.
All right, don't worry.
We have a child in the back seat.
Everything will be fine.
Got to get another get another get a vodka.
Vodka, nice real quick.
Millie was in good hands here.
Me, though, I had more questions and not a single answer in
sight.
huh grab in hand that slice of cheese must man lurks among
the trees la la la la la la la la we're definitely not
adopting her she might have a little bit there might be a
reason why she was locked up in the attic guys not because
she was half true there might be other reasons why
all right let's see uh what's her what's the that explodes
blasting and burning every enemy hit.
Oh, I didn't have enough anyway.
Oh, yeah, I didn't find any comment.
Oh, never mind.
The one who painted a sidewalk was much older than your man.
You know damn well what that means.
He said to keep quiet until he got the money for her.
Ma'am, you don't grasp the gravity of this.
The men looking for your ex will hurt him.
I can rough up a few, sure.
But there's always more than you, than your son.
So tell me straight.
Where is he?
All right, we'll grab one newspaper.
One of the older Mausburg Herald issues.
This one celebrates the spirit of progress, showcasing the
latest inventions and standout innovations from the past
decades.
New World's Fair held in Mausburg.
Featured among the marvels are fireproof of best suits for
firefighters, inflatable emergency airplanes, and a
smuggler's board of colony creations for the renowned brands
under the Mike D.
Umbrella.
Damn right.
Wadka for a child?
At least add a cherry.
You're right.
Oh my god, I almost forgot about the cigarette too.
How would she drink without a light?
So right.
It's so true.
Well, if you're going to the dark stack, I left something
over there.
What kind of something?
you doing at the bay oh well i didn't go there per se the
customs authority withheld some of that merchandise i
imported some of the finest cheese sticks in the world from
a lovely faraway island where beefy artisanal rats roll them
with their tails yeah yeah happily the war benefited you
that much so why not go get him yourself that's the problem
the shipment got stuck in the usual the the the bureaucratic
mess you're part of the bureaucratic mess you're a
politician got lost so probably the problem cringlius around
the docks and you want me to track him down for you track
down cheesesteaks those are silly customs officers couldn't
find their own behinds if ended on it all right sure
consider it done buddy what kind of fucking cheese sticks
are they
it better be like stuffed with extra mozzarella
Vivian's nowhere in sight yeah where is me i swear i made
sure that phone call was Vivian that was not a very good
voice filter from the 1930s all right we got that Oh, yeah,
who done it?
That, I was, who did it?
Why?
Nothing but question marks here.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
And then the old sewer system.
I wonder if there is, like, mice here that are lactose
intolerant.
Like, what do they do?
Did they just die?
It's like, oh, my God.
It's like when people were like, um, uh, 80 years ago, there
were less, uh, there were less uh what was it like 80 years
ago unless people died of insert disease and it's like 80
years ago uh they died by a childbirth that's why like those
types of studies where people like um a hundred years ago
people were fine when with nut allergies and everything now
we have to be so careful about like nuts and gluted and And
they were like, yeah, because they just die.
It was survival of the fittest back then.
They just fucking die when they were popped out.
All right, I go to the water area.
I guess, like, the mice who were lactose intolerant, they
just leave it on the sidewalk.
And they're, like, failures.
Yeah, they died from the allergies before they knew what it
was.
Nothing like a breeze of rotting fish, oil rigs, and stale
Gouda.
Corny would be begging for a gas mask.
Oh, not stale Gouda.
Think about the Gouda.
It reports that outrageously false accusation of blue cheese
abuse against Steve Bando, the fain magician of Moussey
Mystique.
Uh, have been dropped with no further inquiry.
Bando expressed outrage declaring, I keep my nose clean.
Until we're talking, unless we're talking, Sharp cheddar.
I mean, it does work.
What is it called?
Prolong exposure to something actually does help you
develop, like, help you get cured from allergies.
But it's, like, not like like the, like the
non-life-threatening allergies.
Like, micro-dosing.
That's what happened to...
That's what we tried with dad.
And then my mom didn't like it, and they were, like, we're
stopping this.
But I was like, even though it was, like, sort of working,
and then she was like, I don't like that we're microdosing
our dog we're so we we had like this we used to have like
the like appointments with this like allergy clip like an
allergy specialist uh uh for cats and dogs and then they
basically they got like a blood test from dad and then
they're like okay these are all the things he's allergic to
and then we're gonna microdose him um every day so that you
won't be be as severe later on and my mom didn't like that
we were microdosing him so she like stopped it yeah a
fisherman's pop this feels crooked too what's this oh it's
the acid gun hello life guy the water if i were you sharks
are circling just past the buoys and they're looking I was a
Canadian here.
Oh, why is a Canadian here?
Oh, hey, there's a frog.
Hello, little guy.
Who let this Canadian across the border?
All right, I want to grab...
Wait.
Sorry to have ammo for this.
Oh, there is something over there.
He's just from Minnesota.
That's what all Canadians would say.
Perfect cover right there.
Yeah, is this Canadian trying to smuggle alcohol into our
fine country?
USA.
I just want to make sure I grab everything.
Seems to be stuff here, but I'm not too sure.
This is like a little weird how...
Oh, never mind.
Nope, they're like, okay, you went far enough.
Why the well is looking at me?
Well, fishy here.
Dead mice tell no tales.
Oh, there's several doors here.
What?
Oh.
How do I do this?
Oh, there we go.
I'm a little...
I'm a little stupid.
Just a little bit.
Just a little quirky.
Get nice.
We got the money.
Anything here?
Oh, I know.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Sorry.
You should have kept wearing that outfit.
Apparently it was anti-acid.
You might have lived.
If he didn't take off his clothes.
I think that should be it.
Oh, shit.
There's a big boy over there.
Alright.
Is there anything else here?
I don't think so.
We can go in.
Alright.
I drink my little vodka.
the rocks.
Oh, I ain't dead yet, Bob.
Oh, no.
Oh, I can't shoot through those walls.
I can't shoot through the wires.
What's the point?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I'm 98 HP.
I got a drink that can.
I feel like there's going to be a lot of people coming out.
here soon that's way too much HP for three guys way too much
ammo and you till here oh there we go oh
my god finger guns all
right guys try to get rid of the he's Oh shit, he got
closer.
Oh my god, I couldn't see him.
He's so tiny.
Nice.
Sorry, I can't hear you over the rata-tat-tat.
Oh yeah, it was like Cuphead.
Oh yeah, Cuphead bullets.
It's nice of them to just, you know, walk in a straight line
there though.
I really appreciate that.
Didn't have to aim too much.
Okay, that's the boss fight.
it now you better drop this silliness and tell me are you
damn you drop when i say drop yeah to hell with you pepper i
ain't oh nothing wait is that pepper gun because i'm jack
pepper uh-huh in the name of the law patent the police stuff
what's this Did anybody gonna come out?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, that's what the cannonball's for.
Okay, I don't think I...
I think that might be a little overkill.
I do think I don't really need that.
Oh, there he is.
I...
I was like, where is he?
Who is this guy?
Hey, maybe I should have...
Maybe I should have looked at the windows.
I was wondering where he went.
Alright, nice.
I don't have ammo now.
So this is a little awkward.
Give me a sexer.
I didn't realize that I had limited ammo for this.
Where did they go?
There they are.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's good that he disappeared.
How?
Wait a minute.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I might have to eat my cheese.
Oh, no.
Reloading!
Where did my balls go?
Reload!
Oh, no.
I ran out of balls.
Unless...
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Oh, fuck, okay.
Wait, that should be the last one.
Sometimes you knock.
you knock it down.
Oh, I can't believe I ate all my cheese.
Good thing I saved all those cheese.
For emergency only.
Okay, we gotta grab some heals, though.
Alright, see, everything's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
Zero depth stuff.
Anything extra here?
Just want to make sure I didn't miss anything.
Alright, tell me what you know!
That's right!
Then talk.
Where's Bozo?
He's still in one piece.
He's alive, alright.
them up a little i got him locked up near the shipyard gate
up north now for the love of let me go you're spared and uh
bleeding that's right i'll let you die nice and slow and i'm
betting bozos got the weather report now which way to the
shipyard all right we gotta bring that lever on
What did it do?
Oh, it opened that.
Ow.
Broke my legs a little.
Wait, what?
Oh, totally real wall.
Uh...
Oh, I didn't.
I have to use my cannon.
On this totally real wall.
It was a real wall if you think about it.
All right, nice.
Oh.
Yay, acid.
This was the police.
I know there are other guns, but honestly, this gun is so
fucking OP.
Like, I could use it for this gap.
This gun is so fucking strong.
Like, I just gotta shoot them in the head and they're dead.
It used to be the shotgun, but then, like...
The James gun is really just...
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
And then, yay!
I win.
I go this way, or...
Is there any extra stealth?
Money?
There's always money hidden somewhere.
Saving somewhere over here.
I don't know.
But, um.
Just want to make sure I'm not missing anything.
Yeah, it's so accurate, too.
That's what I like about it.
What the fuck?
He's like, he's trying to find me.
I'm trying to find him.
Of course, up and down, up and down.
Eventually, we'll reach each other.
But...
Oh,
it's that totally not a wall.
Oh, that's why there was a cat in there.
Ooh, that's a good level design.
Oh, if not, read this message again.
Okay, this does seem very mob rush-like.
going to be a lot of enemy enemies down here.
There we go.
Oh, front gun.
Oh, that was easy.
I'm starting to think the totally normal walls are not
totally normal.
Well, I feel like any wall would fucking...
would be a not a normal wall if I shoot it with a cannon I
think any wall can collapse with a cannonball against it
nice more cheese oh no yeah I was what I'm wondering like
what are they doing with all these advices no I'm just built
different yeah
snatch the what f you oh it says funk the mustache
goodbye oh shit why is your acid down here oh fuck
why is your acid down here i said as i jump right in
it was fake acid.
I had to double check.
Guys, I had to be sure if it was real or not.
Oh my god.
I swear, officer.
Ow!
I've been law-abiding since breakfast.
Oh, wait.
How did he see me?
My hero.
I wanted to watch.
oh my precious savior more noble than a whole truckload of
blood of tammy's the one you should be thinking just tell me
what i need to know uh yeah yeah it could be fake acid it
could be a fake vat of acid guys you always have to double
check everything well see i was born right here in mouse
bike almost 30 years ago damn he did not age very well
everything about the Shrews oh oh right yeah yeah so uh
there's a meeting going down see they're resealing the
livestock deal or whatever the meat is shrews who's they
cops the crooked ones meeting with some sciencey types weird
accents real heavy on the Z's especially Zaleida see
professor this is some new racket or business as usual.
Oh, business as usual.
Used to bounce around Shantytown, keep it quiet.
Now?
Feels like they don't even bother hiding it.
Bounce around where exactly?
Bob's White Shop?
Latisha's pharmacy, maybe?
Both good folks, just scared stiff.
Oh, and they've been using that old underground shelter
uptown.
I used to squat there till they kicked me in the teeth, see
right here.
Yeah, yeah, tragic.
So when's the next deal?
don't know today tomorrow they don't exactly work on a
schedule and me without even a sandwich for the stakeout
guess i'll start sweeping those spots oh uh speaking of
which see boss i happen to have a key a very special key a
pharmacy key let's just say i'm holding on to it for latisha
temporarily and since the pharmacy's on your list 50 bucks
boss and it's yours No.
I'll tell you what.
You'll give me the key.
And I don't turn your tail.
That's right.
I don't negotiate with trues.
Mouse has gotta eat, boss.
Then chew on the fact I just saved you.
Exactly.
That should be enough to fill you up.
Yeah, I'm close.
Eat those.
Good.
And do me a favor.
Try not to be a turd for at least a day.
See if you like it.
Okay, saved your life.
me for money there were like 20 dollars right here you know
how much 50 cents would have been that's like five thousand
dollars if we account for inflation customs has to be around
here somewhere
yeah we gotta grab this real quick
oh i get the little guys Don't kind of waste no bullets on
them.
A one click works just as fine.
Oh.
I'm at the use.
I got you shots.
Oh, shit.
That's not an overkill, right?
Oh my god, if I had my Tommy, then they'd be dead already.
There you go.
Got Hydrate.
Appropriate reaction for a sniper.
It's not overkill.
If I had a take, I would have done the same thing.
Herbal cheesesticks.
Wait, is that...
Are these...
Are these cigars?
Alright.
Let's bring Stilthin' his delicacies.
Oh, that's what cheesesticks are.
They're like cigars.
Like mouse cigars.
With extra mozzarella.
The mozzarella makes them burn longer.
Oh that makes more sense now.
I was gonna say like what the fuck is he trying to do with
cheese sticks?
There's the totally normal wall.
It's like those, like, candy cigarettes.
Where you can smoke it and then eat it later.
Do I activate that?
Oh, it's over there.
I see it.
What?
Yeah, so it's like those edible paper plates.
What am I supposed to do here?
It's like, I can't press that.
Switch on the side?
Yeah, it's like edible paper slash edible paper plates.
So you don't have to wash the dishes and throw stuff away.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, I'm supposed to break it.
Oh!
I was supposed to break it.
why don't they just like when they like do like code
breaking like if they write some important messages on paper
they should do it on edible paper so they get caught they
can just eat the paper it's like when they have this like
the cyanide teeth if they get caught they bite on the
cyanide teeth if they get caught they just eat the paper and
they have everything can get digested in the stomach.
Or you could just eat regular paper, I guess.
You don't really need to make it edible.
It's just more so for, like, convenience sake for the guys.
You know, for people who don't want to eat regular paper.
Yeah, they can already eat regular paper.
Yeah, but then it's, like, more comfortable for the people.
It's more comfortable for people to eat edible paper.
so it doesn't taste as bad
there are actual edible paper that's how they make wedding
cakes or like cakes in general they love using edible paper
trade renewal agreement suppliers agree to deliver livestock
to lawful recipients weekly for another 14 days by moonlight
at the usual spot fondue free this time short-term gains
long-term rot that's the game the captain and his fondue
loving pal are playing make makes the man wonder what they
see in the mirror no wedding kicks are mostly just fought
like uh what are they called it's mostly just uh what are
the icing thing called an xx scribble was cited in something
that reeks of illegal fondue illegal fondue It's just cheese
though Bonded yeah, it's made of fondant and and cardboard
And sticks to to make the pillars is usually it's just one
tier of the cake that's actually edible
It be super tall is just for aesthetic sakes
Oh What were they doing all three of them grouped up
together like that.
Oh, is that how they patrol?
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have got rid of that pillar there
earlier.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
That's it.
I have to use that.
Is that it?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where's the last guy?
I know that's not the last one.
nice oh fuck it's a sniper he lives okay no there's no way
he lives that there we go I was like there's no way oh
shit there's a lot of people shooting me right now fuck this
guy in particular okay I'm on high ground so oh my god
everybody's Just throwing shit at me!
Your melee!
That's not fair!
You can't just suddenly start fucking doing projectiles!
You're the melee class!
Alright.
That does not overkill.
Okay, I might need some HP real quick.
There was a vent in the basement?
Well, say goodbye to the basement.
I don't think I'm allowed back inside.
Is there any more HP?
There is.
I knew there was like a bunch of HP boxes here.
Oh, there's some patrol mouse.
My basement.
I guess we'll never... It might just be money again.
I'm basically...
I'm basically a millionaire right now in the 1930s.
Okay.
Oh, got a clue!
They hand our seasickness meds to some old world types.
Like it's no big deal.
Some old world names.
And a whole sack of prescriptions for seasickness meds.
We're already shipping the shrews.
Are we shipping them to...
Mount Australia?
Shrew Australia?
Maybe?
Is that where they're going?
Where are the tracks?
Okay, this way.
Why does it...
Footprints keep pointing that way.
I don't get out of here.
Oh, shortcut unlocked.
Okay.
Is there somebody over there?
Oh, there they are.
I feel like I could have done this earlier.
There you go.
Oh, nice.
Then locked it.
Oh!
She'll never expect this.
She'll never expect it.
And if she doesn't walk five steps forward, my master plan
will work.
Gotta make sure.
I have to go through here, but the door's not open.
Oh, there it is.
Went over 100 shrews, moved per shipment.
Where did he go?
What happens to them?
Oh, that was a slow day.
Only 23.
That was a very slow shrews for us.
Oh my god, he's still alive.
That man took four TNTs in the face.
It must be that secret meeting.
Oh my god.
The banjo is going crazy right now.
The five banjo strums.
Is it Canadian now?
Wait, what does the Canadian know?
I'd sure clear the water if I were you.
Charge the circling just past the buoys and you're looking
real longer.
He looked like he had...
Oh, yeah, it was shotgun.
I thought it was a machine gun.
Oh.
His captain goddamn sins.
They're all crooked.
Saying so.
In the 1930s?
Where the fuck is this guy?
Oh, it's the professor.
He's got that particular brand of a quite big affair, and
I'd rather...
No way!
A crooked cop in the 1930s?
Here come their lackeys.
Walking in on me like...
Ah, hell.
Ain't no fucking way.
I was gonna say, where did they go?
Oh, God.
Okay, that's good.
Maybe I stay in this corner.
Yeah, I'm just gonna stay in this corner.
I think that's where I'll be the safest.
Wait, how did they get up here?
No, I should just...
There you go.
This piece was like a bad haircut.
Messy, uneven, and way over my head.
I had to go back.
Think it through.
Oh, it's our bat!
Oh!
Still more?
I thought I killed all of you!
Just a little house.
Houses for them.
Okay.
Do I need extra kilos?
There is.
I think it's the end of the level anyway, so it doesn't
really matter if I grab kilos.
Just do it for the sake of it.
For the love of the game.
All right, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Quiet phone.
Yeah, I was going to say, all your friends are dead.
Why are you still fighting?
All right, back to the office.
Plenty of pieces on the floor.
Time to start pinning them in place.
Boring.
All right, let's go upgrade our gun.
over time.
Someone's in the wrong era.
Next, you're going to tell me unions are real.
Oh, yeah, I want to.
Charge up a shot, fire, crush, fire, crush, catamount
fragments.
Okay, this is where, this is where, like, not, like,
breaking walls type of shots.
Hey, Bozo.
The quite big affair was all a hoax.
No war, no nothing.
Are you out of your goddamn body?
Yeah, I was gonna say, are you fucking crazy?
Was I not there?
Got the purple spade and scars to prove it.
The purple spade.
I'll, uh, the double check.
Damn, Jack.
I didn't know you were like that.
The perp, really?
Maybe the wrong choice of a symbol.
You, uh, you ever wonder...
I don't wonder.
I do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But do you ever stop and think about your, you know, stellar
career?
Jack, I live it.
What is your point?
Well, see, you wrote that big expose back in the day, right?
Toppled one of the mob families.
Yes, Jack.
I was there.
Right.
So now, the family's gone.
Out of the picture.
But suddenly, we got these hitmen popping up out of thin
air.
Just poof and so...
somebody drops they're silent efficient and deadly so what
of it well makes me wonder oh yeah I was gonna say how do
you know what purple is like all it is is black and white
dirty so they erect a firm a company to offload their
dirtiest work like a real murder LLC you get me what I mean
is But maybe the mob, they made something better.
For them, more is for us.
I sincerely hope it's those five-cent novels speaking.
They're clearly frying your brain.
Maybe.
But what a way to go.
John, what the hell?
Oh, so you found that fish.
I did.
John, what the actual hell.
Easy, Jack.
Now, I know it could have been a little tough.
Could have been, John.
I'm not sure it's a little ptsd is striking hard right now I
fought in the war John.
I watched my shredder by shells two weeks John two weeks in
no man's land living on mud blood and rainwater They gassed
us John heavy clouds.
Oh, no, the trenches.
Oh, no, he's ptsd right now gas gas gas So I know hard John
I know hell and I know horrible but this This!
I cannot smell this, John.
There ain't no coming back from this, John.
He fought in the war.
I am calm now.
But John, never.
And I say never.
Damn, the fish is worse than the gas.
Like that ever again.
Capiche?
Did he just say a fish?
Like, I got nothing out of that.
I literally...
He literally said this was worse than war.
And I didn't get anything out of it.
That's fucked.
Can't even put it...
Not even gonna clean my tab for me.
Not even gonna wipe my tab.
This fish smells like mustard.
She sticks.
They smell a little funny, don't they?
Oh, you know.
They're from abroad.
They've got this.
uh mix you know sharpens the aftertaste oh the mozzarella
herbs oh i know what you're talking about that's just good
though you know funny i never took you for a cheesehead well
because i'm not i just need something to calm mind and it
knows from time to time it helps me with my speeches yeah
yeah sure it does jack oh my god 400 she paid me 400k but if
if someone tries to sell you that they are don't trust them
oh he has trust issues you can trust nobody in the 1930s
west belacan asserts german gordon they give the super chat
thank you thank you don't trust nobody not even yourself all
right got my crime wall crazy squints when they all were in
this together the one called the professor shakes hands like
than the shining star of the forest, Captain Sims.
Oh, I resolved the lead.
Oh, I have to go to the wetlands later.
Alright.
The crooked cops are on to me.
Who took this photo?
How did he get this photo?
Alright.
Next area.
Jack, listen up, if you're planning a trip to the
countryside and happen to end up in the wetlands, there
might be a little something you can do for me.
No stink this time, I swear on Shrewd Thicken.
Oh?
Yeah, see, back in the day, I used to run a small processed
cheese side gig.
We did stuff.
All sorts of stuff.
For all sorts of reasons.
For what kind of stuff?
came up with a really great recipe.
Real special one.
Bog fondue.
The fondue was made with bog water.
It lets out a nice aftertaste.
It doesn't quite roll off the tongue.
Won't make it water for that matter.
Appearances can be deceiving, Jack.
Track it down.
The bog water enhances the cheese.
Yeah, just add it on to the pile.
Avast me, Hardy.
How was the stinky yes well the place could use as the
forefathers would say gentrification gentrification you're
gonna gentrify the shrew district i did the cops are neck
deep in the shrew racket dunk like a breadstick in a bowl of
melted mozzarella ah that spells trouble either for us or
the shrews what else did it did you come across well looks
like there was some you're gonna add a coffee shop you're
gonna add a starbucks later of the crooked cops goes by sims
captain sims one in the same terrible news indeed we need to
to tread carefully from here on out that ain't all there was
this scientist of sorts there the way he carried you're
gonna add old foods not at my local shrew district.
Cornelius, I can feel it in my gut.
Either that, it's something that I had for lunch.
Either way, something much darker is going on.
You have to dig deeper, Jack.
Little lives depend on it.
You don't need to remind me with the cheese letters and
play.
The cops likely headed for the wetlands.
I was like, why do you care so much about the shrews,
Cornelius?
Get some solid evidence, and we'll get to the bottom of this
in no time.
Oh my god.
He needs those true votes, guys, to get elected.
But someone's trying to stop him.
Try to take away their rights.
Try to take away their votes.
Not if I'm on the case.
Alright, that's what the fuck?
Okay, the shop is definitely bugged.
The mortician, an old friend of mine, let me see the body
and the dental records.
You sure?
It's the victim?
It's the one they scraped off the payment.
on the toe tag he's older than overage free one thing was
certain the poorest whole line there on the ice wasn't
John's true who did it and why I couldn't say but I had one
more stop to make I don't really like Tammy has any other
quest how come you always got time to hang out I'm fine I
leave now all right let's Let's go.
Oh, new area unlocked.
Oh, there's a sewer level, too.
I see it.
Still locked, though.
A fair wetlands.
Oh, it's a bayou.
The cryptic house.
Oh.
Are you really going true with this?
said so so all we do it these cheese leggers have outlived
their useful useful usefulness yep so we planted bombs watch
the canisters go boom it's an inside job i knew it
i knew it was always manufactured by the government All
right, nice money.
Now we go upward.
Or open that door.
Let's grab this real quick.
Grab the armor.
All right, now we open the door.
God damn it.
All right, who's over there?
Oh, I dropped out.
It was me.
I was the one that's over there.
It was not very obvious that I fell down.
I thought something fell on top of me.
Alright, tell me everything you know.
Oh, man, you really went hard.
What's this raid about, huh?
What are you coppers up to?
Yeah.
I don't know, man.
I'm just following orders.
Really?
I'm sure you can do better than that.
The boss said, uh, plan a few.
bombs uh watch the canvases go boom like sky high he said we
we gotta clear out the swamps rid him of those cheese
legging scum they're no good no more outlived their use
useful all right all right enough i get the picture now i
gotta find the cheese leggers boss holy the crooked cops get
him don't worry he'll be fine we could glue him back
together in the mouse Mospital.
Guys, don't worry.
That hole...
Oh, see, I told you he's fine.
He got up and left.
See, guys, everything's okay.
We can patch the hole with cement.
Oh, it's like...
Oh, there's hillbilly mice.
Oh, I love this.
I love this side.
That's like the classic swinging swinging
Yeah, I fucking love that like the classic swing of course
I can already see like the the swing ladies doing their
little bop their little Betty Boop bop
like this
all right let's
just throw acid in here
yeah the flappers yeah yeah yeah that's what i was thinking
of boys on to defend defen cops be here go to chief mansion
you know where okay for a second i thought i just like had a
stroke trying to read that i was like am i having a stroke
right now?
Am I...
It's like...
I'm like, is it me or is this...
Is it ridden?
Fuck you.
Weird as hell.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, no.
No!
This is bad.
No.
Oh, no!
Wait, is there an unstuck button?
Is there an unstuck button?
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, no.
Okay, how far is it?
How far?
I don't remember when I last saved.
Today's my birthday.
I wish everyone a good day, especially you, Doki.
Oh, no.
Oh, I have to do this again.
I'm sorry, I get to listen to this song.
Also, I made that...
Oops, I pressed right-click accidentally.
But midnight, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear midnight.
We got to jam out again.
There you go.
I'm going to have to waste my bullets this time.
I put my water away.
I keep hitting my right click on it.
Alright, I learned my lesson.
I was trying to do a sequence break here by double jumping
this.
But clearly it was not working.
I was trying to be clever.
I want to look cool.
Alright, nice.
We got our ammo.
Oh yeah, we need to grab this clue again.
A clue believed in a good laugh.
What more could a mouse detective want?
No, you can't rocket jump in this game.
Oh my god, forgot I have to glide.
Wait, I can still do it.
Oh my god, I forgot about this mechanic.
Yes!
Okay, it was just an invisible wall.
Oh, wait, unless...
Unless... Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, I think I can make this.
Oh my god, it's literally right there.
No!
No, my god!
Oh, I thought I got trapped again.
I thought I got trapped again.
I feel like the glide mechanic is so useless.
They only used it for, like, one area.
What did I open?
Okay, I have to...
Oh, wait.
Maybe I should... I have to be here.
I'm gonna go back.
It clearly opened something.
Oh, it opened something on the other side.
Okay, wait.
Just in case.
Just wanna be sure.
Bada, bada, bada, bada.
Okay, I thought it opened that door for some reason.
Alright, keep going doing that bonga.
I'm gonna be right back.
There's a secret in that log?
Which log?
I'm in the forest.
I was gonna say, y'all be specific right now.
I guess we'll never know.
It's all alike.
Game is like, she's gonna be here any minute, right?
Any minute now.
Oh, my god, it's the goddamn sniper.
I have to reload.
Reload!
There you go, I got it.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Get out of here!
Oh my god, eat my cheese.
Okay, that fucked with me a lot.
And my cheese.
Yeah.
Oh no, I have less than seven cheese.
I need more cheese!
The cheese economy is gonna...
It's dying now!
Cheese economy is in shambles!
Okay.
Over here, I didn't see that.
Thank god there was a health potion there.
Really needed it.
Oh, there it is.
That was the area where wanted a sequence break hey there
old-timer what's keeping you busy cooking cheese cards for
my boys and that cheese been tasting fine gonna kick them
hard and pee and together we will dine huh say good fella
does the name perfect bog fondue ring any bells well I ain't
heard that name since I was just a boy and now I can bring
you up the game so you can't spread the joy wait but if you
want them secrets you gotta help oh me and fetch me my
wrestler wrestler I'm mad and fetch me my list of things
couldn't hit the note I got I get you bro I got you heard of
John Brown he's looking for a recipe oh
Ooh, it's hardly a surprise.
He was nuts, a lang, a mess, and cheese.
Goggling was his vice.
Definitely was born in the wrong era.
Collect three thingies for the old cheese ledger.
What the fuck is three thingies?
He was just rocking out.
Let's grab that.
Just find the thingies.
You'll know when you see it.
Is this a thing?
That old hilltop hunt Spookier than a tomb In half is
inviting Just need to find a way to sneak inside Okay That's
what I have to hide ground now Doggos What you gotta do
about that?
Boom Okay that That literally hit him in the head Where else
could it Where else could it go?
I can't believe it.
He actually tanked it.
There's more dogs.
Wait, I hear a sniper.
Alright, that should burn him.
Oh my god.
So many of these people.
They just keep spawning in.
Oh, nice.
Blueprint.
Do I need to go back up?
Okay, I do.
Wait, is the bog bad?
Oh, the bog's not bad.
It's just water, but like a little dirtier.
Gotta make sure I don't take the barrel.
A little bit of some dirty water.
Doesn't hurt nobody.
Okay.
They're not?
Is this?
Okay, there it is.
You see, okay, that has to be where I have to go, right?
Oh.
Oh, I can still make it.
Goodbye.
Oh, yay!
I believe!
I was like, oh, oh, oh.
Never punish.
All right, I might have missed a lot of stuff now.
Now I don't think we're gonna find the three thingies
anymore.
All right.
Up, up, down, down, left, right.
Yeah.
Ooh, that's awkward.
I'm a little concerned if I'm gonna be able to find whatever
the fuck it was over there.
Just do the Konami code simple enough.
What the fuck I pressed Q?
Where do I go?
There's something here I'm missing.
Do I actually have to do the Konami code?
I don't have a B button.
There's no way.
Oh.
Oh, I did.
Okay, I just had to press E.
Thank God for all the ammo they're giving me here.
I really need it.
This way.
Oh, it's...
so dark in here oh somebody's gonna come out of that door
and there's armor
the power was back in trouble and you know what that means
i'm gonna shoot that because acid goes through oh never mind
acid does not go through wood Who would have thought?
Alright, somebody's gonna go through here and I'm gonna
do... Oh!
And then boom!
Kobe!
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, this way.
There you go.
You should burn out here.
No entry yet, so...
That means I should go in here.
Oh, it was just a...
Huh?
Oh, it's just a shark.
Oh, wait.
It was just where I was.
How I got here.
All right.
Yeah, I'm back up here now.
There we go.
All right.
Nice.
Easy enough.
I'm pretty sure I did not do the side quest.
I was able to...
I did not do the side quest.
Because I skipped 80 parts of this.
Of this map?
Oh, now I'm here now.
No cheese leg is in sight.
Gotta whiff a yeast, though.
That's awkward.
I gotta crack the code.
You must let me back up there.
Usually they have shortcuts for the rest of the map.
Beware.
They're just leaving asses here, lying about.
You gotta throw it on the totally normal wall.
Huh.
Some of them thingies.
Oops.
That should blow.
Yeah, I was gonna say that should still reach it.
Uh, left or right.
It requires keys.
Which means I have to backtrack here later.
By the good old 1930s where there's no work no work or
safety laws.
Good old days.
I am closed now.
The windows open, then shut, then opens anew.
Strange shape slips through the threshold of that accursed
house.
Mirrors shatters, but they do not break.
Visage.
Oh, visage.
Visage is still ever present.
Ripping apart my mind with a cheeseless bro- oh, cheeseless
brim, sorry.
I'm getting infected with the cheese.
With a ceaseless bray.
The voice is- oh, the voice is finally saying it's the ray
of infinite light shodding upon for- for- and then I got a
heart attack.
The rest is covered with moss, kibble, and ink blots.
No entry.
Well, I was just here.
Oh, that...
There you go.
What did I fall down to?
Yeah, maybe you spend less time laughing.
Russell?
Are you okay?
Oh, seems like Russell is dead.
No!
I didn't finish exploring!
Every time!
Oh no.
Oh wait, nice.
That's actually where I wanted to go.
Eldritch feeling about this.
Eldritch horror?
Common bogey.
Hard in the absolute...
Silence!
The dissonance!
The song!
Do you hear it?
No.
unknown it seems yeah i can sing too but you won't like it
oh this is not as bad not gonna lie if it's just me oh fuck
okay how did i how would i have known they made holes in the
floor yeah a class a classic turkey
There we go.
Can I just get reloading?
Oh fuck.
Alright, George.
Dynamite number one.
Alright.
Oh, that was close.
There we go.
That was actually like the easiest boss fight.
Under the top, I fell through the fucking floor.
I think that's boss fight.
It might have been pretty poorly designed.
Not gonna lie.
Definitely the most poorly designed one.
Oh my god.
It's an ambush!
I don't know where I came from.
Bye.
Is there anything extra here?
A special that delves deeply into the culture and history of
the wetland folk while the current habitants of the wetlands
are mice and shrews of questionable upbringing.
involved in shady dealings.
It was once a land where proud mice tried to make their own
heaven on earth.
Despite the stench, the mud, and those damned gators.
Alright, we made it.
Maybe there is a hidden another ambush somewhere.
I'm ready for you.
Where are they?
I heard the bell.
Oh god, not the bog water.
Oh god, I gotta hide.
real fast oh wait a strange stick figure resembling a totem
ready to conjure some crazy swamp which stands as clear
proof that the cult is still active in the wetlands yet
there's this itch at the back of my mind the mag is this at
this the tagging the nagging sense oh wait I'm not moving oh
oh give me a sec my thing crashed i got mine all right give
me a sec guys it crashed i don't know how it just suddenly
disappeared it froze the witch it got me it got me they got
her i'm booting it up the curse it's real
All right.
Booting up.
All right, got it.
All right, there we go.
I'm back.
I'm back, baby.
Maybe it is all connected.
Okay, so the water.
Water is bad.
Who would have thought?
Oh, shit.
No!
Oh, God, it's so hot.
The water.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding?
I'm trying to jump over this.
Is that the thingy?
Oh, it's a blueprint.
I still don't know what the thingy is.
I'm still trying to find a thingy.
Whatever it is.
Is it this?
No, that's cheese.
Oh, hey.
Oh, secret.
Gotta get out of here.
Oh, there's the pipe.
Oh, fuck.
Not again.
Oh, no!
Can't get out!
Yeah.
Alright, this probably feels very slack.
Cooper, like, does.
Okay.
We got him?
Do you know a thing for me?
Oh, there it is.
It's like one ring.
It knocked me live.
What the fuck?
I mean, I'll take it.
I think you're a little high.
Oh no, he's drunk.
God doing what they love best.
drinking just like the good old days it's over here but i
don't but i don't but i don't but the heat's already here
damn i need to find the cheese luggers pronto okay i have to
go here which means i'm not gonna go there
that's right you freeze
wait oh i do have to go this way there's just so many
possibilities Wait, no entry.
Except for that one.
I need the cheese logger's key.
I want to go this way.
Alright, nice.
Oh, he's over here.
Oh, there's a pipe.
Oh, secret.
Oh, and a baseball card.
Nice.
Oh, I wonder how many pipes I've missed, though.
Just too many possibilities.
Too many options!
So many doors!
Okay, that's the save point.
Oh, and then the music stops.
Okay, and now I unlock the shortcut.
It's all of them.
Just do all the options!
option is the good option.
Wait, there's a door here, too.
Alright, nice.
Oh, safe.
Nice, I just made it.
Nice blueprint.
Still have not found the thingies yet.
Okay.
You want me to go this way.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, there's the save.
I saw earlier from up here.
I got you, bro.
Are you okay?
You the boss here, fella?
How was?
What?
All right.
So who's the boss now?
It's a...
This was too beautiful to be real.
Huh?
What do you mean?
Them prospects, you know?
Oh, it's too good to be true.
See?
Get a gig for that red line in, Kalfi.
Toss them shoes out.
Show them.
So I finally get to be racist.
Then build some nice homes.
Shops, too, for us.
I even threw in some cash to get the whole enterprise
running.
All we was after
i'm a god damn hoolian hoolion who lied talk to me them cops
the species is a science ball that's right you can never
trust a nerd maybe someone else too, eh?
Why do we even get into moving them shrews?
I was just...
I hoped...
So it's that mouse, French shrews.
Why big offense, you know?
That's like the hierarchy.
That's a fool kind of thing.
Everything was going fine.
Root was clean.
Straight through the depths.
But then, huh?
But then they sent them all?
Can you say that on record?
I'm done for me.
But you, your son, he's coming.
Who's coming?
Hey, stay with me.
finish the sentence say it in my tape recorder
oh my god is it jack is it like a the plot twist was that
jack was the crate was the crazy one orchestrating
everything for all for betty rest in cheese buddy would you
look at my scuffin oh it's my guffin
Oh shit.
Reach the pier and escape.
I reach it.
Oh, right here.
Oh, never mind.
Not here.
I mean, it's not actually gonna flood, right?
Throw me five.
It's not actually time.
Oh, I thought I killed him.
Where do I go?
Quick!
Get the tracks out!
We're back here?
We just escaped.
Oh, there we go.
I'm back in the pier.
I made it.
Oh, I did skip the area.
Oh, we didn't collect the three thingies.
I did skip all of it.
Yeah, I want to accidentally jump down.
whoops whoops guess we'll never know what the three thingies
are guys not the three things my plane oh it's always the
Scottish oh no it's parkour time oh
no Oh, I should not have drank that.
Oh, I should have drank that.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I ran up bullets.
Acid time.
Oh, maybe it's not acid time.
Oh, he has acid bullets, too!
Oh, shit.
Don't let the water!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we gotta eat the cheese.
Eat the cheese!
Nice.
Oh.
Persistent bastard.
Let's see if there's anything worth taking.
If there's still a him to take from.
Alright, thank God for the cheese.
Cheese stonks are going up.
Squeezed lean tracks again.
Those e-jit scientists are gonna burn the trail again those
those blind numpties leave stuff in the desks again deep
fried crowdy hmm aside from the orders to get rid of the
cheese ledgers the notebooks got really only two type of
entries complaining on egypt scientists leaving track down
their bogging devs trail and a cost obsession over his
raided craving for deep fried crowdy from the hooded loonies
at mangia magia whatever that is deeper than a red stick and
hot mozzarella it was time to wedge it into the rest of the
puzzle okay it's time to leave never punished the acid came
in clutch there
bump i guess we'll never progress the side quest
now where is corny Is there anything in here?
I take you heard about your ex-husband's passing, ma'am.
Well, I've got good news and bad.
The good?
The jumper wasn't your man.
He's not mine.
The bad?
He's still out there.
And some real nasty types are looking for him.
Two shrews walked into the hotel that night.
Oh my god, I can't wait to hear what happens after.
This one recounts the rise of Steve Vanda.
who stormed into the magic scene with a bang a newcomer to
the world of illusions bandit is a mouse of great promise oh
i meant sorry i meant when i said jack earlier the magician
i meant steve sorry i forgot i'm jack but i bet you steve is
the is the mastermind of all of this and he's all he wants
to do is bring back betty
his tricks are drawing big crowds to vaudeville's shows and
even and even theater stages and of course like many true
pristine whatever he's joined by a sudden and hard-stopping
assistant one Betty Lynch a young part-time singer and
part-time actress this game allows you to buy the
collectible newspapers yeah yeah I see that but what about
the side the side quest is the it's like the annoying part
so what's the crisis this time jack because i won't they
imagine i didn't grab the ingredient the bog ingredient
listen oh boy i smell a pep talking coming no not a pep
because i accidentally fell down i couldn't get back up why
are you mixing it up with cheese like okay can i buy the
three thingies though no easy answer i was deep in my
anti-jack phase back then anti everything really and some of
those poor sods needed someone who could fix things Yeah,
but no butts Jack the wetlands folks.
They ain't bad guys Sure, some are the hustlers petty
thieves whatever things come up with but that the broke
Without options and well not broke not broken off the four
guns Well, they could do it the right way Yeah, now they're
dead guys So grizzled yet so naive one day when the system
kicks you in the spirit Fine hot enough, you'll get it.
Hey, let me remind you.
I've been to war and back.
Oh, yeah?
And what'd you learn?
Pss.
Smart ass.
Alright, let's upgrade.
What should we have?
Mmm.
I'll upgrade the...
I'll actually upgrade...
Oh, I'll save up for the acid gun.
It just came in clutch several times.
So I'll save up for it.
So, so, Jack.
What did you pull out of the swamps, huh?
Tell me it's something useful.
A big red-lined disappointment, Corny.
These cheese-leggars were just middlemen, relocating the
shrews for a quick buck, making the district clean, nice,
and strictly for mice.
Heck, even the cops seemed like they were on someone else's
payroll.
It's all just some cheapo supermarket cheese, layer upon
layer upon layer.
And right there, sandwiched between all those layers,
scientist keeps popping up with his sleazy look and even
sleazier ideas can't quite put my finger on what if that it
will save all along it's like a superman thing he put on the
glasses and he turned into a nerd but that red lining
business is deeply troubling i wouldn't believe why else did
he have a secret lab underneath his house cheese leger poor
sod is that pity i hear in your wouldn't recognize him
because he had glasses on and i hate being used i can't
stand seeing people treated like tools by those crooked
creeps and fancy suits flaunting their ill-gotten authority
you know that better than anyone corny um excuse me we've
both seen war corny or did that slip your mind we were the
that's real ah right oh well well jack i think it's uh the
best course of action is to hunt down those cultists,
scientists, and put an end to all this ruckus.
They seem to converge in one spot, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, a little too suspicious.
No pissing in the cornice.
I got a bathroom.
Jack, you ever thought about retiring?
What's that?
Oh, you know, taking the girl somewhere far, far away.
Oh, here's a thought.
a woman first you know time for women etc when i'm grinding
for cases no wanda i had my fair share of sightseeing i've
seen enough of the old world my place is right here in
mouseburg the real melting pot yeah across with the cess not
like i can't get any woman i'm just so busy you know
i'm married to my work guys everywhere and i we don't need
no mania We're here to solve cases, not get distracted.
Lords forbid.
And we got time.
The solve cases.
All right, we got this.
We got the little creepy voodoo dog.
Oh, we resolved a lead.
Yeah, we're missing this middle portion here.
so uh the hell's bonja and manja or a secret show both got
cult fingerprints all over him gotta talk to someone who
speaks street and majors and crazy since a strong lead with
this one
oh bozo think dale what do you know about yeah um well spike
these got quite the following so uh sweet lyburn no
something more classic like i don't know crazy trigger happy
big on rogues Scientology like crazy uh not much to go on
but your kids are now doing a speed run in Scientology where
they break into like Scientologist offices and then try to
see how far they can run from one end to the office to the
next sealed heat all that jazz that's crazy like brian
cocker after a solid swing last i height they've been
hanging around the secret show grounds yeah apparently they
started swarming the scientology offices i got a murder and
two crazy leads point me straight at it oh they have it
mapped out they have a plan of course huge fair can't miss
it clouds mimes the whites must have been there at least
once no i hate uh anyway boss the bestest of bestest bosses
the grounds are like the perfect spot for the cultists and
crazies they blend right into the crowd maybe all right we
gotta go to mangia mangia
yeah they started doing speed run of the offices so they're
trying to map they're basically trying to see how far they
can get before they get kicked out of the office and then
like they it's like they have like the they have it like
partially mapped out now because it's not public like what
the offices are like and they swarm it so they're like catch
me if 20 of us run in that's crazy there's like tick tock
videos of it and everything where is it it's all visit curds
mercy and have fun finding clues i'm gonna go to the sewers
it's next to me yeah they're they're road liking it
They say you either die a stinker Or live long enough to
realize You need a shower I never figured that one out Oh
wow They have a nice little hardy hole down here Oops
Oh boy no bullets I was like why is it nothing coming out
Oh Gators
Ooh this is bad Oh I don't have any ammo.
I'll use my shotgun again.
It's been so long.
That's all raid.
Yeah, they started speedrunning slash raiding the labs.
Simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's actually wild.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, now am I allowed inside?
No?
Is there like secret area down here?
Go back!
A group of people dressed up as minions and one roost out in
front of Anvil asking for Dom Cruise!
Oh my god!
And Golden, thank you for the super chat, thank you that's
actually crazy.
Oh.
That's what I was missing.
I was like, where the fuck is That's a hole.
Be crawly, Vincey, mousy.
I'm Tomodachi alive?
I didn't know if I should need that.
I knew it.
There we go.
One of these.
Oh my god, you guys are still alive?
That's it, I'm throwing the acid out.
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta take a picture.
There,
I got it.
Transport cages and scientific gizmo.
Most definitely connected to the shrews and science.
Oh, shit.
How did I die?
What got me?
I was trying to take a picture.
What are these?
whoops
who's shooting me oh he's over there
all right now I can take a picture one points to another
oh oh shit no that's not what I want it let's try to kick oh
Oh no, I ate too much cheese.
My cheese.
Bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
Oh shit!
Oh that's awkward.
Alright.
I'm gonna do it twice.
I know there are two taps.
There you go.
Wait, are they...
Okay, I was gonna say...
Are they immune to acid?
It's because they live in the sewers?
Alright.
We're good.
We're okay.
Oh.
We might be dipped in acid, but we're okay.
If fucking finally I got James gun ammo.
There we go.
Thank God.
We got a real gun now.
Wee!
Oops.
I'm going on them?
There you go.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Should be fine now.
What did that turn on?
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Oh, fuck.
There's another lever that I didn't push.
Oh, whoops.
Oops.
I didn't realize there were three levers.
I thought it was one.
My bad.
I was like, I should be done by now.
Whee!
What the fuck?
I should grab heels, though.
Bop-bop.
Is that all?
Okay, little guys.
Tap, tap.
Oh, shit.
He's beating me up.
All right, now that should be all of them.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure the government will compensate for their
wives.
I'll make sure, I'll make sure the wife is properly taken
care of.
Do not worry.
No wife left behind.
Okay.
Oh, that's damn.
Oh my god, who fucking dropped a vat of acid on me?
He's gonna eat the cheese real quick.
Okay.
Oh, I'm running up cheese right now.
see I'm so thoughtful I'm so considerate oh you're back is
it morning kind of dark in here I dark it be shell but I can
show you the way to the light but I won't die right of
course you will baby one day same as all living things well
most all turn around sale once I go down we'll be meeting
soon oh oh my gosh she wished them elevator back oh my god
witchcraft she brought the elevator back oh what the fuck is
this an underground city there's a whole damn city yeah bio
shop five
oh right that crazy old shrew wants to play oh it's true
city it's like the mole people before she finds me new
thicket oh god they're all so tiny
it's where the mole people live oh shucks it again yeah yeah
that's that's like the first time this week gotta tell john
or jack or what's his name you know the fixer it's this way
all right then i'll go this way am i even allowed here oh
wait how did you get beat up don't mice here
spike d is mice don't trust him Huh.
There's a code here somewhere.
Where would the code be?
Eh.
It's not boobs.
Oh my god, it takes fucking forever, too.
I didn't do it.
If I know anything, it's never boobs, guys.
Getting into the thicket of it.
I'll see myself out.
Acer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's never boobs.
But sometimes it is.
That's just coke.
Work now, die later.
I'll grab that.
I can take it because I'm a mouse.
I don't need a pay.
I just have the mouth diff.
Let's see.
I'm just trying to see if there's anything.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, up here.
Oh.
All right, bless me.
All right, I'm up here now.
Now I'll talk to you.
Long time, no see.
We met five minutes ago.
Topps.
Oh, time be a funny thing, baby.
Moves different for all us folk.
Anywho, what got you sniffing around here?
huh just looking for clues and you dig up any shell one but
one ain't much ah we quantity quality both got way no since
you fresh around here i reckon i'll toss you a little longer
voice acting in this game is just really really good i can't
believe they're able to get like the the devs able to get
like caravan palace and like a lot of really famous voice
actors see the place be falling apart elevators busted pipes
leaking like a crawfish all i can think about every time she
talks like gambit never falls take this might come in handy
for long now go do what you can't lady you are real bad
mamma jama bad luck to bless self-dokie is it but who else
would bless me this one opens with a striking article about
the unfortunate events that took place in its true thicket a
village largely populated by the smaller cousins of mice due
to a wave of public outcry some redder amendment of mice in
the spirit of righteous indignation destroyed several
properties there were casualties surviving shrews escaped to
the oh my god they basically have no rights we gotta drink
that we the people us
oh okay i can't jump down here oh what happened to me oh
wait there's something over there no no who would let me
wait did I oh I go it went backwards okay I literally almost
made it too totally normal love got the totally normal love
oh take a picture of the the corner chair oh oh it's Steve's
key and another piece of the puzzle slide Oh, that's weird.
Why is Steve Cape here?
That is pretty weird.
Convenience, it's a heartless damn.
But now the mob probably had a scent too.
And my clock was ticking.
It's time to hit the road.
All right, there we go.
We move on.
There's save.
That's weird.
We just saved.
Raiders, you know, that smells like a union.
Fix the bow, she said.
Yeah, no pressure.
Yeah, nothing to worry about.
Okay, I'm...
What the fuck?
He's still alive?
Okay, I legitimately thought that that would have killed
him.
Alright, ready.
Oh!
Alright, no more.
No more bullets.
Any more?
I have the high ground though.
Oh, I gotta reload.
Okay, we have to go up here then.
Broke my legs.
Oh, nice.
It's fine, they're not gonna come back for it anyway.
Yeah, I don't have any bullets here.
Ooh, that's bad.
Okay, oh, there's a pipe.
Reload?
Secret!
Why did you get in here?
What the fuck did I- Oh, I must have got this money.
This secret stash.
That's it.
I'm grabbing the acid.
Peek me.
There you go.
Good thing he peeked me.
It's great that he listened to me there.
There.
What else here?
How do I fix this?
Am I mechanic too?
Oh my god, I know everything.
I know it all.
Mechanic, PI, Engineer.
I know there's gonna be a mouse that shows up here.
What the fuck was below me?
Oh, it's just crocodiles.
We can wait here.
Hey guys!
What's he gonna do?
Holy shit, these crocodiles are resilient.
Oh, fuck, what the fuck?
Oh, they're right below me, and they're always right below
me.
I hear like, they're the chomps, and it freaked me out.
Oh, I have to go up?
Let's grab the money real quick.
Up we go!
We can fix this.
This is fixable.
Oh shit!
Okay, that wasn't fair.
That was...
That was an ambush.
Got me on the backside!
Grab the acid.
There you go.
Am I worried it gonna come, huh?
I got a barrel of acid.
I ain't afraid of using it.
Boom!
Oh, shit.
Okay, we gotta eat the cheese.
Oh, wait.
Am I time?
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, wait a minute.
it uh wait where's the sniper
oh my god it is time
all right now i know i'm no more cheese cheese is gone oh
what the fuck oh
Yeah, I think it's stopped.
We're good now.
Wait, there is a...
There's a safe over there.
But how do I get up there?
Can I see that?
I think I can.
Must be a way to get that.
I don't see no pipe or anything either.
Oh, it might not be that.
Oh, oh, there is money here.
Oh, just grab the money.
All right, up with you.
Okay.
Find another valve.
All right, there's fruit burning.
Oh, no!
Oh!
Where are they coming from?
Got the hot ground.
Where else could it come from?
Oh, that's right.
Can't get me.
Parkour!
Oh, I found the valve.
Oh, shit!
Oh, that scared me.
Because they're stuck in the corner.
I should kill them.
It takes like four to five.
Is there any extra?
Oh, nice.
I need that James gun ammo.
Alright, I am running out of acid, though.
I'm gonna have to make a trip to Home Depot soon.
Okay.
Is that everybody?
Where are the rest?
him movement yeah it is strong but i have a very limited
ammo for it so that's why i've been using it for emergency
but now i'm just like it oh
what the fuck all right where's the last one i didn't hear
no bell should be one more Is that really it?
Oh.
There we go.
There's the bell.
Wait.
Oh, I can't make it.
How do I make that?
There's a ladder.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I...
That's what the switch is for.
I was like, I don't understand.
How do I fucking get up there?
I say as I look at the switch, that would...
Give me the ladder to get up there?
I've used up all my options.
There's nothing else I could do.
Oh, survive the onslaught.
Oh, it's a survival tab.
Oh, shit.
I didn't mean to kick it.
That was an accident.
There you go.
Oh, that is unfortunate.
use my I actually use the oh oh good thing I clearly just
spawned here what
am I getting shot at god damn it's always above me these
fuckers always like they always be able to like hide and
play inside it how does he do it
That's right.
Not this time.
Oh, nice.
We did it.
Let me make sure I'm not missing any items.
They know.
They know gamers don't look up.
Oh, that's where the safe is.
Uh.
There's nothing else here.
I know that's it.
Wait, how?
But you were...
Hi, hi, Petit.
Lost again, are we?
No, not exactly.
Just chasing some weird magnetic gizmo that swipes something
I need.
Well, how quite do I learn to do, you know?
Best you be fixing that.
Or...
Or you know, oh shit.
Their laundromat gonna feel like a cool wetland breeze
compared to their alternatives.
I would really like to know what the hell you're about.
Oh,
thank God.
She's finally using her witch powers.
She's using her magic.
I thought she was going to help me.
Oh.
Oh, there she is.
It got lowered, right?
Nice, the sweet old witch lady helped me.
Wait, did she?
Oh, she did.
Yay!
Finally get my one.
Alright, save.
Okay.
Oh, of course.
Of course there's always a trap somewhere.
Every level survived the pit.
I actually prefer the gun.
Not gonna lie.
I think the gun is much stronger than the spinach.
Alright, can't do anything.
If I shoot me to the left, it should me to the right.
There you go.
Slide!
Punch!
Big punch!
Oh wait, well that's their normal height.
Technically a head punch.
I can't block this!
Oh shit, okay, this one will be hard.
Big guy would be the hard part.
Unless I just punch him there.
I stun lock him.
Oh, I forgot about kicking.
All I can remember is my fist.
Okay.
Come
on, get out of here.
That's right.
Get sunlocked!
Oh, shit.
You guys, friends.
Get sunlocked in the corner.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, now that's illegal.
Why are they allowed guns?
Wait a minute.
I wasn't allowed gun.
Okay, now.
Alright, there we go.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It's a frog!
It's a fucking mosh pit!
There we go.
We got it.
We survived.
Really, really.
moshing there.
We're just even watching.
Is it just shrews?
High score.
What the fuck is Paul?
I definitely punched more than 28 of these people.
Oh, that's the plan.
Nassia's part of the wetlands.
The map was cryptic.
Stick shrews, egghead scribbles, all pointing straight at
the quagmire.
hit me i did not know what cryptic ball the goat
a touring edition it features a town of betchaville best
known for two things mystery novel writers and adorable
dialect the former especially plentiful though some critics
claim they're just writing the same book over and over again
so much so that they could turn into a cheese chugging game
take a sip of blue cheese fondue every time a novel includes
a wistful reminiscence rap bullies or or takes place in some
bumhole near Becherville.
Is that a parody of Sherlock Holmes?
Or Baskerville?
Yeah, you'll never beat Paul to score.
Oh my god, Paul from the Invincible?
Yeah, no.
I don't think I'll ever live up to Paul and the spaghetti.
Or the Stephen King.
What is he gonna do?
do.
I'm a hot ground.
I get these bugs out of here.
Let's see.
I know for sure we definitely have to go here.
There's like exploding barrels everywhere.
Oh, we gotta swim down there and fix the valve.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I gotta save first.
Alright, time to hold my breath.
I'm I'll make it I'm so gonna make I'm so healthy that did
it oh yeah drains it too all right that's convenient turn
to the old true lady where he's like everywhere y'all be
specific
gabadum oh it's gotta be specific the old lady he's she's
everywhere Wait, where is she, anyway?
Okay, is this way?
It's this way, okay.
Oops.
Yay!
God for the mattress.
Okay, there she is.
Oh.
Thank God there was a conveniently placed mattress over
here.
There, I did it.
The flood is gone.
Much of blood, sir.
see you just like one of them high and mighty industrialists
what you try to do something end up making a mess figure a
way to fix it didn't pack yourself on their back like a real
winner that's me I don't feel like a winner not one bit daco
but did you find what you've been looking for yeah no though
I did find a whole lot of curious stuff on the way I found
the cave mm-hmm yeah Well, as a detective, I feel like it's
about the goal.
For my job, not really.
If we can get finished the case earlier, that's even better.
That means I get paid faster.
You still got plenty more to wade through.
Is this a spoiler or what?
Oh?
Oh, elevator.
Oh, back to the office.
Okay, we got...
All right, what's the code?
guys what is it guys what was the code guys i know it's not
boobs but i will entertain you all
oh my these take forever too look
see it was not boob guys i told you i knew it wasn't boob I
told you.
It's never boob.
1925?
Why not?
Alright, let's try that.
It's never boob.
One day it will be.
Because you're missing the five.
Because there's always more than one boob.
I wish you could do this faster.
We do not need to see the animation of him.
flipping the numbers.
It's not 1925.
Oh, there's four different codes.
Well, I guess we're leaving.
I don't know why that's barking.
It's not a feeding time.
I wouldn't even know where the hit is for that area.
Like, I haven't seen any numbers at all.
I was in the, I guess the newspaper?
Maybe take a bath.
Dad believes in boob.
All right, give me a sec.
Actually, did you stop barking?
Never mind.
I'll then check up on him.
It's Mr. Pepper to you, kid.
For an orphan, she seems very happy.
I might be.
Oh, they're on posters?
Oh.
If I'll get a...
Oh, bring me balloons, Jack.
All right, I'm going to check on him.
I won't get in trouble.
Wait, all right.
Let me finish reading the lore.
Okay, okay, okay, Billy.
I'll get you some balloons.
Oh, he stopped?
Oh, he stopped.
Okay.
Yay, he stopped.
Okay, never mind.
Give me a sec.
Oh, we didn't tell her.
We didn't give her...
Oh, that's...
I mean, not great, but alright.
Alright, I'm back.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, he's let her live in bliss ignorance, I guess.
Hello, Tammy.
Oh, what about a thing that zips you straight where you need
to go?
Think fast, track.
Maddie, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, well, you can't be the first to invent everything.
All right, little bit too late.
We're sort of not there anymore.
He's like, to save the world, you gotta...
I got it, what?
I need one more.
Oh my god.
There we go.
We'll buy another newspaper.
The Zarko speaks about Mouseburg's most exclusive nightclub,
which has become a hub for his shady dealings, ranging from
illicit cheese tastings to under-table mousetrap bets.
It sits right beside a monthly pamphlet praising police
efficiency.
Hi, I arrived.
Sonic.
Jack.
Wanda?
You got anything fresh for my piece?
Oh, yeah, I did.
The place is a pit stop for the kidnappers and the
scientists.
They're dumping the shrews somewhere in the swamps, Wanda.
And it's not the cheese leggers doing it either.
It's some crazy eggheads and a bunch of lab coat mice.
The price of progress is asking for trouble.
That may be, Wanda.
This ain't about, Steve.
i mean it might have been at the beginning but it's growing
larger and larger like a a gargantuan cheese whale rolling
down a hill man you can't stop it i don't know if anyone can
it was originally a missing person case now i have to deal
with cults yeah yeah maybe i should take a bath and
silentology what no oh just follow the lead that's what i'm
doing woman
Let's see.
Go follow the science, yeah.
Oh, we resolved the lead.
Nothing but swamp stink, bug bites, and bad omens.
Why drag the shrews out there?
Oh, it's all coming together, guys!
Everything's coming together!
show keeps showing up in places she wouldn't she shouldn't
who is she and what's her title all of this points to
another all right we gotta head to the wait check the street
secret show head to the quagmire balloon packs all right we
gotta go to the show they want to know how many more levels
i have left
Because this area is still locked here.
Am I at least halfway?
I can't tell.
I can't even tell I'm halfway.
Okay, Jack.
It's just the job.
The clowns will be there.
And that is okay.
Oh.
This way.
Well, well.
If it ain't the fun, police.
Better circle around this bunch.
Or I can shoot them.
Hey guys No entry You ever get bored saying that I'm
surprised they don't even shoot me I mean I Shot a lot of
their buddies Are we like Parlaying right now There's a
ceasefire Merry Christmas
Oh that's a lot of gangsters
There are 24 levels I don't even know what level I'm at
right now Oh, totally normal, whoa.
Am I missing anything?
No.
Alright, nice.
No hesitation.
Oh, yay!
Okay, I can upgrade the acid gun now.
Oh, now I'm halfway.
Oh, my god.
Wait, this is a long-ass game.
I mean, it's like a mystery.
too so you're trying to slowly crack the piece together all
the clues I can't believe I'm halfway now I feel like I've
done a lot of shit too
I'm almost fully max level on my guns so I'm surprised not
that stupid sniker I gave have a lot of freebies there
yeah oh my god he's back oh my god he's fucking back okay
there you go just have to kill him
get out of here you can save that again hun oh now the whole
season's ruined and i was so looking forward to the clowns
I'll never understand your thing for those bozos.
You can say that again, Bob.
Why are they watching me?
The dressing room key.
I should have used the acid more.
I just wanted to nuke the sniper.
I know.
We're only seen half the cheese puddons.
The fact that we're only halfway full of cheese.
Wait, is that where we came from?
Yeah, that's where we came from.
Still want to take a little sip, though.
Call me full HP.
Secret show ticket.
One out of one.
Oh, I guess they don't care that there was a gunfight behind
us.
Investigate Kurds murder scene.
There's a quest item on the floor?
I really miss it.
There's so many dead mice Can't tell where it is Oh yeah,
yeah The The shooter was all part of the show Oh, it was the
Oh, you're talking about the ticket I got
I thought you meant it was something else
Oh, that's where he died Oh, it's a clown It's okay It's
okay There he is.
I got a drink.
I got a drink for that.
Secret games to get tickets?
How do I play the secret games?
Oh, I found a secret.
This one features an alarmist piece about carnival grounds
on the outskirts of Mouseburg.
Supposedly the land was an ancient squirrel burial site.
Later, the scene of a tragic mining accident were settled.
Shrews met an unfortunate and eventually a hotspot for shady
deals and bizarre experiments today it's a thriving
community of circus performers stage musicians and members
of various cults whoa what a place what a place to host your
doors lava not a cloud I just have to live Oh shit, I didn't
see that.
But how do they live?
That's not fair.
That's illegal!
He literally pushed me to the ground!
I'll grab the sniper at it first.
Okay, thank God the sniper showed up first.
There we go.
You're nice.
Oh shit.
Alright, we gotta get him out.
Nice, easy.
We win our prize.
Yeah, we got a ticket.
Alright, we gotta reload, though.
We gotta get armor.
Gotta get all our ammo back.
I don't think we're getting all our ammo back.
We might have used up a bit too much for this area.
Yeah, I only used my...
My James gun, too.
That's fine.
Oh, what's this?
Okay, nice.
Oh, hit me.
Oh, I got armor.
Alright, one ticket.
One ticket, please.
Okay, hi, noon.
Oh, shooting range.
Oh, I'm good at that.
Oh, whoa.
It's finger guns.
Okay, never mind Okay, I'm not used to the finger guns,
though
Okay, this is different It's not my James gun
It's not fair
I don't know how to lead with my fingers
Alright, there we go
Oh, I can literally just hold my hand Hold my hand Alright
There you go, nice.
Easy.
I didn't realize I don't have to just click.
I gotta rob some dead bodies real quick.
That should be everything, right?
Yeah.
Alright, another ticket!
Ticket!
Where is another show?
That's it.
I only see two.
Where could the other one be?
Oh, that's a sad cloud.
At least I will open that door.
It has to be, like, somewhere else in the circus.
Alright, let's take a picture of this.
Boop!
I'm never gonna financially recover from this You're the
chief around here Who?
Me?
Ah, you want to rob a soul in my wound, huh?
You're what?
And you're what?
He's Italian Yeah, something like that So tell me what the
hell happened here Can you see her?
Francesco de Alfonso He killed Mr. Curda Francesco?
and an opening good night mama me i wish you would stop
doing that stop a water stop being italian jack that's
racist well we had a rehearsal francesco was high on the
water that mouse ain't a shrew we can't say that to him yeah
i don't know what that is he's not irish hot he walked in
the line and he he fell well i for me oh deal right so is he
now and why does it look like a tornado hit this place oh
this elephant oh he's a really a domo look at a mess he went
straight through on a props wasn't just panic right see see
francesco's got a bit of a problem huh let me guess cheese a
chug's like a water huh oh he has a cheese addiction
water don't tell me he's afraid of mice she's seen these
clowns were behind it i hate clowns and mimes you stupid oh
no what are you against the irish back in the good old 1930s
there were a lot of things people thought about the irish in
on francesco you see anyone messing with the equipment hey
crowd was a fool you could have been anyone i take a look
around I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
He wasn't actually Italian.
The accent was too good to be true.
Hey, man.
Hey, is this the way to the elephant's dressing room?
Yeah, but as you can see, cleanup's still a mess.
You'd have to be like...
ass is the wind you know run on walls can you do that yeah i
don't think i can or even want to don't let your dreams oh
just do it oh my god it's shot of the rat
okay i can run on walls now how does that work
i guess it has oh it's like those Oh there it is.
Whoops.
That even possible?
Can I do it?
It's tough.
Oh, I did it.
Hello, Jonah.
Okay, I just have to hold it.
Oh, oh, she... Yeah, she's drunk drunk.
Yes?
Uh, hey, I'm, uh...
Oh, no, the police?
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm a private dick.
Oh, the language.
As in private detective.
Just here to ask a few questions.
You do that high wire act often?
Yes, sir.
Since I was a baby, it's my, uh, Coupe de Grace.
Uh, yes.
Yeah, Coupe de Grace indeed.
So what went sideways this time?
I don't know, sir.
Swear on my mother's grave.
It just happened.
Well, not much to work with.
But everything cracks with the right nudge.
I mean, I think we sort of know what happened.
I didn't do nothing bad, sir.
You killed a rat.
What do you mean?
Oh?
You killed a mouse.
crime of them all.
This one offers to profile one of the most prominent Big
Mouse party members.
Jacob Buns, better known as Perogi Jake.
Buns or Perogi as his friends call him, was once a
small-time croak operating in the depths of Wallop Bay.
Thanks to the rehabilitation programs spearheaded by Milford
Sawyer and Miles Kurt, Buns turned things around, launched a
legitimate business, and quickly rose to become one of BMP's
most loyal and trusted members.
I don't know, it doesn't seem so trusted to me.
They gave the, yeah, the elephants an alcoholic.
I didn't do nothing bad, sir.
Really?
Then why is there a bucket of blue cheese leftovers in your
room?
He was drunk during the act!
Marco was supposed to dump...
I mean, take out the trash.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, relax.
I'm not here to arrest you.
He was drunk on the job!
Now talk to me.
Where'd you get the cheese?
Oh, God, he has a problem.
He needs an intervention.
He never discloses his suppliers.
All right, let's try this another way.
Was it your regular dosage?
Same dealer?
No.
Oh, my God.
He was high and drunk.
it was he was blitzed kind of a fishy with a side of the
heavy perfume the the cheese tasted funny the cheese
addiction but but but blurry and then well you know you
panicked i knew it was vivian i told you she was she's a bad
mouse she's a bad rat one of the three rats is a rat oh the
the the training my career crumbling what i done so I've had
to my room straight through the decorations so crossfaded on
cheese mozzarella gorgonzola sir all right I think that's
off for now get some rest and lay off the cheese oh we'll do
sir oh another ticket see
I told you something was off cops all over and now a pi bet
it's got something to do with that dame what dame third row
the one you were ogling right up until the elephant dropped
on that poor guy and don't give me that i have a squint bs i
do have a dame or maybe a femme fatale time to check the
audience seats i'll go back
Oh, you're gonna see that.
But, just gotta be sure.
Alright, I'm hacking.
Nice.
Oh my god, hacking to another hack.
Definitely used.
Just like the ones down at Walla Bay.
Oh.
Oh, he borked in.
There's There's nothing in the balcony right now.
A double hat.
Okay, where the fuck is the vent?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, up the vent I'll go.
Twas a magnificent evening, my dear.
Aside from that little cheese incident, though, with that
dumb elephant, though, he is a good boy, see?
Just can't lay off with cheese.
If he ever discovers the blue, we are doomed doomed there's
a high-profile meet after the grand spectacular spectacular
colo regular thing on the ground backstage invite only the
police some old work that I need to get dad here he's being
a little you know bratty
all right back you know he's being he's like he heard the
Italian accent.
He wasn't happy about it.
There's a hot...
Oh, where was I?
Very exclusive.
I'm kind of big here.
So I might get you in, eh?
Until tomorrow.
Ciao, Bella.
I'm leaving my wife immediately.
Oh, shit.
A high-profile meeting.
Yeah.
Can't afford to miss that.
The same.
Oh, there's the key.
Excuse me, sir.
I need the key.
Okay, I I need to talk to the...
Wait, not the Elefano.
Then find the manager.
Okay.
I mean...
Oh, I got two tickets.
When did I get two tickets?
I don't even remember getting two tickets.
Oh, God.
The dog got me.
Oh, my God.
He's slapping me.
Nice get more tickets win the prize Oh, hey, yeah Leave no
bottles standing
Yeah Got another ticket
Oh, I thought that was another thing I can win I was like,
I'm ready to win another ticket guys
What you gonna be pack of deflated balloons oh i got the
balloons all right nice
there it is that was there you go found the side quest too
in here
and here's train exhibition Okay, one ticket out of one.
Oh, here.
How do I play this?
Aim window frame.
Huh?
Oh.
I'm not timed, so it's fine.
Oh!
Oh, uh...
Oh, fuck, okay, wait.
There we go.
And then this one.
Oh, I...
I still have one more.
Yay!
First try!
Look at that.
I'm such a natural.
What are you buying?
Easy.
Oh, what you're buying?
What are you selling?
I like that.
That's a Resident Evil parody, a reference.
Yeah.
Am I missing anything down here?
Just gotta be sure.
Wait, did I get anything down here?
Look at that.
First try.
Every shot landed.
Remember to use false arrows.
Oh my god didn't realize I didn't realize there was a lock
there.
Oh my god, not again
It's fun I knew I knew it was too good to be true I was like
whoa, what is this convenient little candy candy machine
doing here
I wonder if I had anything to do if anything you do that
we're shooting stuff that would be silly that's silly
there's no way
oh my dogs left
wait can i actually not go back no oh wait yes i can yay
we're so back there you go Oh, another hack.
Yay, more money.
Oops.
Oops, that's all my HP.
Actually, there is a...
Hang on, there was a jar here.
Alright, we'll full HP again.
I don't know.
I thought it would break the wall.
I know it says...
I know it didn't give me any hint whether or not it's a
suspicious law.
What?
Those are all the shrews.
Wait, wait, I need a chalkboard.
Got him.
at the big one he counts for two because he is very large
yeah and uh wait wait i need a chalkboard i dare you say
owned one more time oh who did that detective jack settler i
was told you might interfere you just blew up half my
caseload so yeah i might interfere got rid of the evidence
i'll keep this free oh my god who is he
who was he oh my god
oh my god this is worse than an average sniper
oh my god where is he oh my god he's right behind me
Oh my god, he keeps spotting him behind me!
It's fine.
There we go.
We'll have to finish this another day.
I'm cash in hand, hourly, and my time's up.
Gotta hurry before my bookkeeper clocks are.
He's like half-faced.
Guys obsessed with Westerns and...
Ah, forget it.
Not your problem.
Wait, wait.
Who hired you?
I'm not your enemy for now, but don't mistake me for a
friend.
A hitman with a bookkeeper who has a Western's obsession.
This they just kept getting wilder.
Had to snoop around the Tensel's back lot later.
For now, let's see what's left of my suspects.
Uh, legally distinct two-faced, half-faced?
Guys, I can't see.
Two-faced guys.
DC's gonna get him.
Say hello to my little friend.
I realize he was the parody of Scarface because that's why
he has...
He has half his face with a scar.
Not the lawyers.
I just want to make sure I'm not missing anything.
A strange key card with an even stranger mark makes me
wonder what door it opens.
Now that is weird looking.
What is this even for?
Are we not going to free the shrews?
Oh, we are.
Okay.
And girls?
I'm a girl.
My apologies.
And the girls.
And kids.
Whack in there, man.
You really went the extra mile.
you making me blush still he got away ah like a little
coward you'll get him next time i'm a hero yeah and and
besides yeah yeah you deserve a prize i do i do yep a real
one show him tommy righty oh miss jackie ta-da a ticket oh
oh a ticket a ticket yeah great for a show no sure a boat
ride big party real classy how did they get the ticket then
so right there on the ticket i'm pretty sure shrews aren't
allowed on classy boat rides found it in one of them cops
pockets he was um uh relieved yeah relieved of the burden so
now yeah oh my god we're gonna go on a riverboat we're gonna
go gamba i guess that's what they do in the river boats so
uh can you free us now the was fresh out of secrets finally
i could leave the clowns to their circus and put the old
brain back to work well don't worry somebody will come in
here and free you guys i'll be right back
and then she was never back
oh it's steamboat gamma time
I do hate the mines and mysteries, especially weird ones.
It was time to pin it to the wall and see what shook loose.
I think this will make up for the fact that her dad's dead
and I killed her uncle.
No, they're deflated.
But I got you a whole pack from the carnival.
Look at that.
By the way, your uncle's dead.
Anyway, hire a half of some balloons.
And don't call me child.
as big as Tammy.
Well, your mouth already is.
Excuse me?
Oh, I got a card.
Alright.
They forced me to use the closing argument.
I'm the police!
Well, uh, I used to be.
It features quite an essay on the fable squirrels.
Mythical creatures of forgotten times whose crumbling
temples are still preserved.
Wait.
are asex the squirrels are latinas in many parts of our fine
country scholars post these beings were likely our ancestors
their ruins are filled with stone statues vaguely resembling
bushy tailed rodents unfortunately not a single one has
survived intact so we're left asking the same question what
the heck no the latinas they're gone nobody saved the
latinas So, how was the secret show, Jack?
Did you have an absolute blast?
I love squirrels, Sonic.
Awful accents, but funky blue cheese.
It's true.
This is truly a dark world.
It's why it's black and white.
Did you at least find anything remotely useful for your
investigation?
Sort of.
Between the crazy clowns, the vehement vendors, the
elephants, Uh, embarrassed, eerie, exhausted.
Ah, for the love of...
Cut the alliteration.
Did you find anything solid?
I did find something solid, yeah.
A perforated card.
What's it for?
Now is it?
That is for a card slot.
Wow.
Exquisite deduction.
What does it unlock, dummy?
I am still working on that part.
I can't believe the Latinos went extinct.
Pretty standard security key card.
What a cruel world we live in.
Some things are.
Yeah, it feels kind of unhinged.
Looney even.
Looney, huh?
We're gonna go to a looney bin.
All right, now we have enough for this.
Uh, now work on...
I think I'll do the pistol next.
Oh, Tammy wants to talk.
Politicians are, Millie.
Are Millie.
Are always making promises and never showing up?
Yeah.
like that he's probably up to his whiskers and handshakes
and empty promises election season you know yeah well he's
never around anyway think you could call him you're less
scary than uncle take carra maybe he'll actually pick up i
wouldn't bet on it oh tell you what here's a nickel go see
uncle john grab yourself a soda and if i hear from your old
man you'll be the first to know all right really really busy
sooner or later that's why he's not picking you up yet he's
just oh you know politicians always working don't worry go
entertain yourself with a penny it wasn't even nickel I gave
her a fucking penny he's just yeah he's just at the farm
upstate really
the assassin bride about some book in the tinsel avenue
might be worth checking out feels like he's a mob but like a
mob inside the mob mob bookkeeper and a cowboy obsession huh
i know just the kind of saloon he'd crawl into
talk is a strange dame showed up at the secret show when
miles current met his unfortunate end
yeah i've seen that symbol before just can't put my finger
on where under some murder scene that's for one of those
fancy steamboat cruises armor thank you for the 20 gifted
ships thank you thank you I really appreciate it thank you
so much Iron Maid alright we do not fight who said that oh
it's down there there's a protest Oh, no.
Not here.
Not in a million years.
Yeah, get out of here.
That's right.
I'm here for freedom.
Alright, we have this area opened up.
And stay out!
Alright, we should go to the other... What was it?
The swap.
Take the Quagmire.
Okay.
There's so many jobs.
Oh, showed a ticket to Stilton.
Oh, I forgot about that.
Yeah, we're not letting him advertise in my neighborhood.
I know that for face.
Your aunt is something, aren't you?
It ain't democracy and fighting for peace.
I ain't no peace.
lay it on me, support.
Word is, there's this fancy steam.
where those crusty lobbyist types gather to play who
controls the world over cocktails I got reason to think all
the cheese strings tied to the shrew racket not on that deck
I've even got a ticket pretty sure I'm not on the guest list
though oh let me see that hmm where I'll be hmm I know this
party I know the boat I know exactly where it docks color me
impressed and suspicious like really suspicious you sure
you're not mixed up in this yourself how do you know please
check i'm running for my mayor remember i get invited to all
kinds of hoity-toity and the nonsense nobody's truly clean
as a politician cornelius i usually send the stand and gotta
keep my ear to the ground but i'm not about to step in a
pile of trouble for fun Don't try your products where you
eat I'd never makes the cheese taste funny Oh that oh that
first time for everything you know and let's go into the
details this thing's no good without a proper referral but
but you could go as my representative two rats one stone
what do you say Where it's usually.
Right.
Just take my hand to you, Cornelius.
You'll all be too much of a coincidence right now.
Also, Vietnamese.
Thank you, Mr. Prachat.
Thank you.
I don't give a shit officially.
One year closer to us.
Could I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can.
Uh, Vietnamese, Tiger, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear tiger.
Yeah, happy birthday.
All right, let's go.
Let's go to the swamp.
There's so many areas to go to now.
Oh, yeah, I unlocked another one.
Here's the Gamba boat.
I think it's like here.
We'll do the swamp next since it's like I'm just going
through the order of the order I locked them in.
Why is it this?
The quagmire.
Oh my god, dad.
Dad is so bratty today.
He wants to be fed early, but like, I can't let... I'll give
him a little bit.
Just so you can... Just so he can... He can calm down.
Alright, I'm back.
But let's take... Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's winning.
He does it when I'm streaming, too, because he knows I can't
do anything about it.
He knows, he's like, she's streaming, get her.
She's weak right now.
She has to entertain.
She has to do her job.
Well, Ballistic, of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Ballistic.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Oh, my God.
He also recognized, he knows when to end stream because he
recognized the phrase bye-bye whenever I realized because I
was in a call with some friends and I was like oh bye-bye
and then he instantly started barking so then I now realize
he connects the word bye-bye to like me to like being like
oh it's time I can be a bitch now he's like oh it's feeding
time because usually whenever I stream I go feed him or when
I end stream like go take give him a walk so he knows
bye-bye means like it's dad time whoops well it's because i
already fed oh shit oops oops sorry i put accidentally
pushed my empty bottle oh i'll grab it later i'll grab that
later oopsie
oh not that
there you go That should kill them.
There.
Oh my god, wait, he's a...
Holy shit, he got out of the car!
Oh, oh my god, forgot about this guy!
I keep forgetting about them!
Better stick to the cage trail.
Because surely not another guy won't show up.
It won't pop out of the fucking car.
Surely...
I
think it was like three.
I'm gonna use acid.
There we go.
Oh, cheese!
We need that.
Oh god.
Give me that cheese, boy.
He's like, my cheese!
And I know my cheese!
Oh, I should need that though.
Ooh.
Oh no, the poison.
swap oh not the poison swap can't see jack it's dark souls
time okay
oh yes the anguish screams the people that killed very
relaxing
or how the fuck is he alive
whoa Is the boat gonna move even more?
I can't tell.
Yeah, I'm just making sure the boat isn't leaving me.
Oh, fuck, okay!
Whoops!
Oh, that's awkward.
Whoops, might have interrupted a party here.
Grab all the heals.
That's everything, right?
Willow wisps are working overtime today.
That's it.
Where else do I go?
Alright, what do the geeks tell me?
Huh?
Oh, the key.
Look, it was black and white, okay?
It was a black and white with black...
Oh, shit!
Black and white on top of black and white.
Oh, now the boat's a little faster.
See, there's an extra here.
Why we're in the swap?
Isn't he not missing?
Nope, there's more poison.
What a cozy little settlement.
Whoop.
See.
I'm gonna stay up here.
Okay, you should burn right now.
I feel extra safe.
There we go.
You should burn the death here.
Yay!
Oh shit, I might as well.
Alright, any more?
Any more rats?
That's right!
I got the hard ground here, rats!
Oh, there's more.
I know there's more of you.
Oh, he hit over there.
Of course he did.
You little pussy.
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Looks like these cheese players missed the memo on.
Or I might have taken a lot more damage than I should have.
Unless there is a little...
I might have just stood there and let him just shoot me
while I stood still.
Might not have been the smartest thing I've done.
Oh, there's cheese.
Oh, cheese.
Oh.
Wait, cheese.
Yay, cheese.
So healthy.
Oh, hi.
Looks like I'm on the right side.
Oh, God, the gators!
Ah, the gators!
I was like, what's chopping my butt right now?
What could it be?
I'm missing my ass.
Get gated.
I got it.
And my Tommy gun just in case.
Alright.
Oh, it's because I hit- Oh no, it's not!
I thought I accidentally hit the lock and that's why they
freed it.
It just happens just like that.
Okay, oh.
What's in here?
What is that?
Oh, money!
Yay!
It sucks for that guy, but yay for me!
This is gonna pay for Belize College Fund!
Oh my god, I was like, who the fuck is making those noises?
Every time.
Yeah, I burned down their homes.
Definitely trouble.
Melting.
Oh, whoops.
Get out of here, I'm reloading.
I need to start using shotgun against that guy.
couldn't help it.
How much I still have a lot of ammo.
Oh.
Alright.
Talk to the other lady.
Talk to the shrew.
Well, if it ain't my petite help for cheese wedge, don't
tumble back on a destiny's lazy Susan have you?
Lady, I inhaled so much bog stink.
I barely remember my own name.
Maybe I ought to put my cauldron off the double.
This place, it ain't some...
Look, I might have accidentally shot her, but it was more...
It was like a precaution shot, you know?
It could have been a rat disguised as an old lady.
It's like Little Red Riding Hood.
I had to be sure.
I had this place with her own two paws.
Live off the land.
Fed the critters.
I had to be sure.
It wasn't a Little Red Riding Hood situation.
But...
But what?
What?
But the same company she ran from bought out the whole area.
Booted her out.
Since then, this place's been home to all kind of shady
folk, cheese leggers, them scientist types.
See, magicians!
I knew it!
There's something wrong!
I knew Spencer!
I knew there's something wrong with Spencer.
But it worked the other way too.
Witches, magicians, scientists, folk- I'm back!
Hello?
I'm back, guys.
They got me.
The magicians got me.
All right.
Let me see.
I got a check.
We're back.
We're back, guys.
Sorry, the magicians.
I got too close to solving the case, guys.
I got too close to the source.
The serious game.
lady i inhaled so much bog stink i barely remember my own
name i got too close to the truth maybe i ought to put my
cauldron off the double this place it ain't some regular
shack is it used to be shed some 40 year back belong to a
little shrewd lady one of them office folk tired of punching
clocks built this place with her own two paws live off the
land fed the critters bug off all that question about cheese
some say she was a real witch but but what but the same
company she ran from bought out the whole area booted her
out since then this place been home to all kind of shady
folk cheese leggers them scientist types magicians part for
the course with this we'll talk about i will say anything
about the magicians right just might but it worked too
witches magician all magicians folk like that they don't
leave a good people they're just hard honest workers went
down in that old uphill resort a fortnight ago well you can
see for yourself what resort all in due time shell all in
due time my right i got a trail to follow when it's getting
cold so how do i get out of here oh that part's easy you
need the key of diamonds just the key of diamonds that and a
little creativity but i've seen you work shell you'll do
just fine one thing before you go that little shrew lady
you've been talking about that you oh god forbid baby i
might look old but i'm much Much, much older.
Oh, she was definitely talking about herself.
It's big on the inside.
Damn.
Let's get him out of the way.
Got the little guys first.
Nice.
That's right.
Use the high ground to protect.
you?
High grounds, my turf!
I'm just gonna...
Oh my god, I saw him throw... Oops.
Holy shit, how many shotgun shots do you take?
And then...
I'm gonna shoot these two.
Alright, I heard the bell.
That means it's over.
High ground is my home turf.
Gotta make sure everything I got everything I need.
Whoa.
Oh.
He just disappeared.
Oh my god.
I might have spabbed so much acid that he literally just
disappeared.
And she's gone again.
He evaporated.
Yeah, I erased them from existence.
Dark room key.
Who needs the old world anyway?
Let's focus on the ongoing World War F.
Oh, okay.
During the so-called quite big affair.
And, oh, wait, is that World War I?
And the one question nodding everyone's thoughts.
Why the heck are you fighting someone else's war?
Why must our soldiers spill their ink and sweat in the old
world's nomad's land?
The answer, if there is any, remain quietly unspoken.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Alright, I'll just sit up here.
In case there's... Yep, there it is.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
They got... They got their dad.
Is that it?
Alright.
They brought their dad to the party.
I don't like this.
It's a fucking maze.
Oh, okay.
No.
Oh.
I...
Why are there a lot of...
Why are there a lot of dead mice here?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Hmm.
They're not moving.
I just had to be sure.
I just had to be sure that they're not moving.
For now.
I knew it.
I know we were missing some down there.
Oh, what the fuck?
Who the fuck exploded?
Oh, I hear the spooky noises.
Oh, I could just...
Oh, okay.
Like, how dare you interrupt our little cult session?
It was their bonding time.
Oh, you're still alive.
Mommy...
Oh, fuck!
Cult in the barrel!
Your mommy-daddy bonding.
time right there all right no more hidden cultists all right
into the vents I'm venting you know it oh shit reloading
Where else do they come from?
Behind me, aren't they?
Alright, nice.
That should be all of them.
Let me in!
Oh, the door is here.
Oops.
That's where the door is.
All right, make sure we grab everything.
Nice.
I'll make sure I got everything before I click on it.
I leave no stone unturned, guys.
All right.
All right, any more?
I looked up this time.
All right, then you should come here to the right.
Reloading.
Oh, fuck.
All right, nice.
Door open.
Oh, oh, I was here before.
Oh, nice.
They left.
Look at that.
They left all the money for me.
Nice.
How sweet of them.
All that free money they left as an offering.
And then the door will take me to somewhere else.
Yep, I knew it.
It's like a little maze.
They just keep making more of you, huh?
They won't know.
See, we're so safe.
Oh, fuck!
Holy shit, they did so much damage.
Oh, it's because it was dynamite.
They were throwing dynamite at me.
Who would have thought?
I was gonna say, what the fuck?
How did I take so much damage?
It was just dynamite.
Pure dynamite.
I know you're in there.
Goddamn cop car.
Fucking clown.
20 clowns in the car.
So that's where the crooked cops were ferrying the shrews.
The uphill resort.
They put him in the crazy house!
And dynamite's earth.
I learned that today.
You guys know that?
Who would have thought?
Oh, I didn't...
Oops.
I didn't need it anyway.
I'm just that good.
I say with 20 HP.
all right let's leave let's leave this joint
there's like so many levels like you see there's like four
that i haven't opened yet just near the city
something tells me the next step is pinned to the end of the
gray string
everyone's i was right on time
one of the mouseburg hero in these partakes a chaotic stab
at the recent wave of missing reports despite the editorial
disaster is painfully clear when it comes to vanishing
rodents mice are on the front page news while others barely
get a mention tragic apparently not that tragic all right i
really am i do i have any more guns left i wonder for
upgrades uh because i feel like i'm almost done upgrading my
guns We're back.
Where'd you run off to yesterday?
Ah, just following some leads on Tensel Avenue.
Oh, I kind of wish I'd gone with you.
Why?
You think you missed out on something special?
Bah, the lights, the glam, the smell of genius in the air,
and plenty of fresh cheese up for grabs, right?
Cheese.
Look, kiddo, the Dream Factory is still a factory.
It may look like they're creating old worlds, but in
reality, they're just shoveling that.
number nine call i mean if you're a screenwriter sure maybe
i don't know but the stars the tinsel stars shining so
brightly above us like a space mice or maybe some distant
gods uh oh you know what would make my day a damn fine
poster with an autograph from some big celebrity i i don't
care Who?
Just something to brighten up my workshop.
I'm a celebrity.
Please, please, please, please with honey and fused Brie on
top.
I could just forge a signature.
How would she know?
She doesn't care who.
Because they're snorting blue cheese and doing things you
wouldn't believe, right?
Oh, quit being so negative.
Blue cheese is cocaine?
Oh my god, they gave an elephant cocaine.
Even if he's just through a screen, it can make us feel like
like all's right with the world.
world like we're home yeah but i already am home no wonder
he was up bro oh it is hollywood though it is hollywood the
show must go on oh my god they gave an elephant coke just
like the good old 30s 90s 30s what a year
Never mind.
Mr. Brown, two glasses of your finest fondue.
Coming right up.
All right, you got something on your mind, or we just
drinking the drink?
Oh, so fondue is alcohol.
And blue cheese is coke.
You know, politics, the backroom deals.
And just right before the Great Depression, Hollywood was
crazy.
huh so we getting sentimental now right you are my friend
you know cocaine bear welcome cocaine elephant those were
the days uh us three against we far and do is cheese and
beer i thought it was just melted cheese i remember it
different oh yeah a lot of smoke a lot of gas and that sound
you know the one like a drop of water that won't come out of
your ear oh yeah oh oh cheese and be I did not know that I
thought fondue was literally just melted cheese no wonder it
takes so fucking on to me
jack wonder wait it's chocolate fondue wait what about
chocolate fondue because I think about like chocolate fondue
where it's just melted chocolate what no i mean actually go
there it's a dead end for the missing shrews and steve's
cheesecrumb trail ends right at the front gate too so what's
stopping you from getting a room with it's chocolate fondue
just chocolate there's chocolate and wine you really needed
to run this by me do the kids know that punch in no idea all
right time to get scanned by a kid This one's a prominent
piece about a new political...
Oh, no, I already bought that.
I already read that newspaper.
Okay.
Chocolate!
Vandu doesn't have alcohol, I think?
Oh, he just wanted to have as many clues.
I rose up and nobody walks in or out east since they skipped
on some shanty-shmanty locks try to sell me the same
newspaper that kid of course the old nut houses crest ain't
the sanest spot on the map but i got that card and just
enough crazy to get in am i like the only detective in this
fucking town like i feel like i have like 80 mysteries to
solve the more i fucking discover the more mysteries there
are like i i think that's just a little too much too much
for one rat all right let's go i need to get water i'll be
right back
okay i got water but i also need to oops we're back again
i'm
back uh wb solid uh many thank you thank you thank you I got
my cheese fondue.
Got my fondue.
I'm ready to head over here now.
What was this area?
It is.
Oh, I crashed.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, there you go.
The assassin Scarface is hit.
The western back lot.
Mousetown.
This is towning big enough for the both of us.
This was where the hitman collected his pay.
And someone was signing the checks.
I'd give back my last dime.
His bookkeeper knew the whole story.
All right, where is he?
How can I just drop...
Oh, well, not drop it like that.
Ooh, that's awkward.
I want to get out of here.
And there you go.
You dropped it, Doki.
Oh.
There it is.
Well, well.
Film set drops.
Film set rules.
Oh, it's so quirky.
Oh, fucking.
There's the sniper.
There you go.
What a love song.
What a lovely song to murder on.
Where does a guy who cooks the books go to unwind?
Perfect song to commit murder.
Make sure I got all the ammo on me.
Nice.
Oh, geez.
Oh.
Oh, definitely the wild wild.
I just got my coffee.
City town ain't big enough for the both of us.
I hear they call him Bond.
Municipal Bond.
Extremely effective.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that is a lot.
Nice.
Okay, that's not fair.
We have our finger guns!
Oh my god.
It's so annoying.
I hate that I'm like restricted to my fingers.
It's how I knew somewhere in the world.
I do realize, I do notice there's not a lot of contrast in
this game.
I know it's like black and white, but the contrast is like
not as like prominent in this game.
It's like how, like, I don't guys know this, but black and
white shows and films, they use, like, they don't, they're
props, they use, like, different color, like, bright colored
props to increase the contrast.
That's why, like, in the Adams family, if you see, like,
what the set decide looked like before the black and white,
they use, like, pink and stuff to, so, to enhance the
contrast.
But, I noticed that.
I was, like, playing, I was, like, oh.
like same z color a little bit
so this were you but especially for like a nor nor game kill
other things too oh wrong place wrong guy stronzo i ain't
sure watch you buddy i'm running low on time and even lower
on patience how this ends depends like the grays blend in a
lot which i've noticed stuff is that like a pizza topping
well ain't you a comedian now i know this And I know you're
the guy signing the checks.
How do you find out?
Just now when you confirmed it.
Just now when you send in like 20 people that kill me.
You must know where the cash flows to.
Like, say, paying some starlets, keeping them entertained,
keeping them quiet.
And if they don't stay quiet, I hear that's another expense.
Am I warm?
I'd never.
Look, I ain't here to audit your sins.
I just want the truth about Betty Lynn.
Help me close this case and maybe I keep my attention on
that instead of your other expenses.
You ain't getting it.
This thing goes deep.
If they found out I talked, no forget about it.
I'm out of here.
Yeah, you can't hide from the mob.
Wait, he's getting out of here.
Wait, he's like, yeah, right, you're gonna get out of here.
Wait, he got out of here.
Hey, sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Go, Jokey, use those powerful fingers to penetrate your
enemies.
Wait, that came out, right?
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Get lost.
I ain't spilling nothing.
Capiche.
So loyal of you.
Oh, fuck.
Too bad it's gonna get you killed.
Oh, good thing I didn't walk right through there.
All right, nice.
Is he just gonna stay there?
Oh, he can fall out!
I didn't know that!
Somehow I always end up talking to the guy running away
instead of running into the guy ready to talk.
Just killed him before they can run away.
That's why you shoot first and ask questions later.
Oh, that's where they're gonna go.
How do I get up there?
There must be a... Oh, here.
That's how I'm gonna get up there.
Oh, wee!
Oh.
There you go.
I love how they gave me the wall jump mechanic, but I
haven't used it yet.
At all.
Oh my god, I was like, who the fuck is hitting my shins
right now?
am I helping the shrews when they're also like when they're
also working with them
hmm just like they might not deserve it
hmm why not oh they almost got me that's fucking right I
know your games okay never mind a second breakable wall.
Oh, oh, a third breakable wall!
A fourth breakable wall!
Okay, maybe I don't know your games.
Okay, never mind.
I guess I didn't know your games.
They would never expect a fifth breakable wall!
And they were right.
I did not.
I didn't expect a fifth breakable floor.
Okay, just as I was talking about this.
Like, we heard you talking about our run-up of wolves.
Not all the mechanics you've learned will be here now.
Oh, I'm not gonna be here.
Yeah.
Holy shit, that scared the shit out of me.
Oh my god, get this guy out of here.
I should kill him.
Oh yeah, a comic book.
Now I know you didn't kill a poor guy.
I still don't know what to do with you.
Alright, this is like...
It's all the comic strips.
I'm finding them not in order.
So I'm like, how did I get here now?
I didn't kill him.
See, I made good money with some bad folks.
And I almost gave him a bit too much fat off the top.
So I figured I better disappear.
No, no, no, but I got bored.
I gotta reread this story when I get all the comic strips.
I'm pretty sure I'm reading them out of order right now.
Is this...
This way.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Yeah, I just need two bullets now.
I was like, how did we get here?
It's like when you skip a cutscene.
in this show.
Oh!
Oh, and running like hell is just for your figure.
And they didn't expect me to actually chase him.
Thank God the director yelled cut and then did a retake,
reshoot.
Like, wait, you're not supposed to be over here.
I almost got him, though!
I was this close!
Whoops.
Oh, where's another one?
Are they all dead?
Okay, they're all dead.
Alright, ammo please.
Ammo, please.
Nice.
I got it.
Let's go.
Is there anything else here?
Oh?
Oh.
I'll grab this.
I made it.
Where did he go?
I got asked this nice old lady.
That way?
Thanks, kid.
And nice threads.
Oh, is she a fan?
Oh, I thought...
Oh, it's an extra.
Okay, I legitimately thought that it was him dressed up as a
lady.
He honestly, she did look like...
The accountant dressed up as a disguise.
I was like, hmm, I wonder where she could be, could be.
If that means drama, I don't know what is.
This is, hey, I was like, yeah, of course you know where he
is.
Oh, he's right here.
Thanks, Will Smith.
Now I know what a TV dinner feels like.
Please, they see me talking to a gumshoe.
I'm a dead man.
Dead or alive, you're coming with me.
Where is he?
Oh, fuck, the goddamn sniper.
Alright.
Fucking knew it.
You're still alive, okay, there you go.
I say, how the fuck are you still alive?
That's it, get out of here.
Alright,
this is not over- oh.
It's not overkill.
What?!
How do you-
Nice.
We did it.
I'm gonna say how the- that guy was so thick!
There was no way you could dodge that!
He's practically eight hitboxes!
Alright, grab as much stuff we can here.
Assume it's like...
Down there, right?
Yeah, it's down there.
Oh?
Where's that coming from?
Okay, whoop.
That away.
Take the money.
I got everything.
Oh, it was the gears.
That's what I was hearing.
I was like, what the fuck is that sound?
Nice.
All the ammo back.
All right.
I'm going to go get the papers.
Get the papers.
I don't think he's going to get the papers, guys.
I guess that's one way to face the music.
Wait, where did he die?
Wait, how did... Did he die?
I looked away.
I looked away for one second.
Where did he go?
I literally turned around for one second for loot.
I guess I will never know.
I saw a loot.
And he was gone.
I blinked.
Alright, there it is.
I have a turtle letter that points to more than a few names.
probably more than one case.
Funny how things work out.
Our little curd-shaped headache got sorted thanks to the
uptilly lady.
Shame she doesn't know when to quit.
Grab some cash on a tinsel stash and have you know who put
this new problem to bed.
Wrong way on a one-way track, runway tweeting trains never
coming back.
Shouldn't be hard to find.
Run away train never going back.
Y'all, welcome to Manifar.
Welcome, welcome.
That's a drop spot.
If the books are there, this could be my lucky break.
Oh,
she didn't die.
Alright, bring it in here.
About to go down here.
Alright, to the mines.
Alright, that means I can explore this a little bit.
Let's see if there's anything I'm missing.
To the other mines.
What the fuck?
What mines am I in?
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god!
Oh, shit.
I'm taking a lot of damage right now.
Like, where am I?
Oh, nice.
Blueprint.
Alright.
It was worth it.
I got a blueprint.
I was, like, in a mine with in a mine.
Oh.
Oh, there's more mines than this mine.
Yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Got a shortcut.
There is this here, too.
Wee!
No.
Oh, God, that was scary.
I think I fucked...
Yeah, I fucked it up.
Yeah, that didn't make sense.
There we go.
Yay, blueprint!
Alright.
You like that flick there?
That's fucking right.
You don't ambush me.
I've been in the war!
Whose bright idea was it to turn that mess into a movie?
I feel like somebody's going to come up from here.
Suspiciously, a lot of anvil surrounding me right now.
A lot of ammo and money.
I wonder what's going to happen.
I'll take that, actually.
Okay, this must be some kind of foreign film.
Okay.
Oh, you thought I didn't see you?
Uh, try to hide in the dark.
There we go.
Okay.
Where did the bear go?
Where did it go?
Holy shit.
Okay, that's the tankiest mouse out there.
Oh, you thought you could hide in the dark again?
That's fucking right, I see you.
Try to do the same shit again.
Alright, nice, we got it.
So I fooled me once.
Shame on me.
Oh, they shoot it.
Oh, I didn't know they could shoot it.
Why don't they ever do that before?
Are you dumb?
Or something?
That's why they're henchmen.
I'll drink that.
Don't quit your day job, guys.
Follow the railway.
But there's stuff inside here.
There's a book in here.
There's cheese!
I just want to be sure I'm not missing anything up there.
here.
Oh.
Okay, there's TNT.
Alright, the totally normal wall.
Okay, this way.
Oh, there's stuff here.
Oh, never mind.
It's just bullets.
Hardcore.
Some acid?
That's it?
Where the fuck am I?
Well, well, well, what do we got here?
Oh, what do we have here?
It's a key.
Oh!
Oh no.
Oh, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Okay.
There you go.
That's how he opens the door.
What if I look behind me, maybe it'll be gone.
Don't follow the Dan train.
In my head, I just thought, oh, maybe it's gone now.
You know?
Alright, nice.
Unlocked.
Some more cheese.
Oh, a little handbook.
There's a ton of likely useful intel here, but the real
attention grabber is the underlying date.
Item.
Date of just a month back.
One dead actress.
Delivered by Mousetrap Inc.
16 tons of blue cheese.
some fancy spiked e-home gadgets and oh look at that one
dead actress hell of a shopping list and one hell of a
smoking gun I had got the evidence now I just had to frame
it real nice for that Dame without losing my head I knew it
wasn't inside job it's all coming together now my butt um
what is the day was secretly a cat under cover.
Oh, not there.
Sorry, I'm a little drunk right now.
It's okay, it was the 1930s.
Everyone was always a little drunk.
Alright, time to have it out with that damn fine woman.
Oh, there she is.
Worker strikes finally stopped.
It features a major editorial arguing that the ongoing
worker strikes had to be stopped and destroying Allied mass
service against the workers was only and best course of
action.
A casually toll appears on page 16 and to 18.
Oh, that's not good.
How about extra newspaper?
Moss Man Lives.
This one seems to hold some story, but soggy, soaked in mud,
and smeared with some green substance.
A red-painted Moss Man Lives is splashed across the front
page.
The remaining pages are just untellable gibberish and
gobbledgoog.
The newspaper is dated 08 2025.
This is from the August 2020.
Wait a minute.
It's from the future.
Oh my god.
There's a time traveler mouse somewhere.
Hey, Jack.
So?
Simmer down, Spark Plug.
I got your poster.
Yay, F in A!
Now, Jack, if you were my papa, I'd point a smooch right on
your cheek.
With a hug.
Just don't ask.
I got it.
Tinker's honor.
Cross my tail and hope to die.
Oh, I got more.
I got more blueprints.
1920.
No, it says 2025, guys.
I can't believe it.
It's the newspaper from the future.
All right, Vivian.
So Mr. Pepper.
Did you find the culprit?
Oh, I would say I did.
Well, don't leave a girl in suspense.
Turns out it wasn't Kurd after all.
Oh, damn.
Such a shame he died.
Yeah, a real shame.
Thing is, something hasn't been adding up lately.
Ever since I paid a visit to Curd's mansion to be precise.
Hmm.
So I find the kid, right?
Next thing I know, I'm neck deep in cultists, the BMP and
the mob, with a cherry on top.
Then, right in the middle of that mess, Curd dies in an
accident at the secret show.
Yes, that was quite unexpected.
Is it, though, Vivian?
It took me a minute to piece it together, but see, Curd...
met his end right after i spilled the beans to you vivian oh
yeah and while the mob may have done betty in because it was
the mob or their militant arm it was the contents of their
ledges that connected the dots with a note about some stuck
up dame drowning in perfume and death warrants and no amount
of perfume can cover up the rod beneath right viv oh Oh, you
wound me, Mr. Beppe.
But let's not be rash.
Perhaps we can...
She's too hot to go to prison.
If evil, why sexy?
You win cups behind bars for killing Miles Kurt.
Great-A scumbag he might have been.
He didn't kill Betty.
Tisk, tisk.
You're no fun, Jack.
But, well, I got places to be.
countries to escape to hold right there what what damn that
fine woman where'd she go where would have failed vindictive
starlet go how did she disappear we almost got it why did I
have to monologue her before arresting her where the fuck
did she go yes this is why you always handcuff
guys a witch beautiful dangerous and on the run where does
the vindictive mob hounded starlet disappear to they're all
connected they're all witches they're all magicians they're
all connected
Vivian's back at tensels no doubt that grudge is gonna be
the end of her their filth yeah just not the trigger happy
kind see all right oh my god we just have this little space
left and also this area i will do one last level and then
we'll call it made a lot of progress today though how
many levels do i have left chat does anyone know are going
to the gamba boat we ended
boat but don't but i don't know but i don't know eight more
to go all right good place a good level to end for today
let's go gambling seemed easy find sims snap a pick victory
was practically in the air
Alright.
That seems pretty easy, not gonna lie, the way he said it.
I just want to wear boss fights.
I feel like I'm picking all the levels that have the boss
fights.
What a lovely breeze.
Hey, mister!
Yeah.
Mind taking a picture of us, mister?
Who let these shoes in?
I didn't have the money for a wedding And well, you know,
work, work, work Oh, they're the Oh, they're workers here
I'm keeping I was gonna say I had to get a vouch to be here
How did these trues get in here?
How romantic?
It's bring your wife to work there
That's this way I want to go this way then Oh, she's
blocking the way Why are you guys down here?
Go fucking put that luggage.
Put that luggage away.
Oh, I didn't take their picture.
Whoops.
There you go.
Here you go.
So, this is your honeymoon?
Oh, you'll betcha.
Long way from home.
Traveling by boat.
And making a buck along the way.
Marriage is fine, but bread on the table much better.
Gotta work.
Yeah, thanks for the photo, Mr. Here's our address.
Now, uh, back to work, honey.
See?
I'm not a bad person.
I still took their picture.
I, I recognized them as fellow mice, too.
Look at that.
Boom.
But, um, I see them as people, too, with rights.
Whoa.
It's over there.
Well, this boat is falling apart.
A toast.
Great that they're leaving all this ammo lying around.
God, he's so rich.
I left it on the fridge, you absolute lemming.
Great.
Just great.
Guess we can kiss the party goodbye.
Oh, great.
Just great.
Here's where he kissed the party goodbye.
Let me share this.
I'm uh...
Press?
You could be the shrewd pope for all I care.
No card, no entry.
Move along.
I thought I have a vouch from the mayor.
I guess I gotta track down that pass.
What the fuck?
What happened to my plus one vouch?
I'm angry now.
I'm gonna say so funny thing about that card you've got one
second okay okay okay can't believe it he forgot to get me
the card the cigar lounge oh Pete pre-party oh my god we're
pre-gaming fucking go maybe somebody left the card here Or I
can go here.
Grab the money from the poor shrews.
I'm not an evil person.
It's on them for just leaving it lying around.
That's their fault.
I'm not robbing the poor if they are just so...
And they're just so incompetent.
And just leaving it lying on the floor like that.
Is it really my fault?
Good.
The five-year wage
Non-lived captive sims
Oh a real technological marvel we got here Yeah, this boat
might not be as well built as they thought where's the
gamba?
I was promised gamba
Okay, this way
Oh, there's a lady reading.
Oh, the vet.
It's the riverboat.
There's always Gamba on the riverboat.
It's a hell of a lot of blue cheese in one place.
Yeah.
You press.
Good.
Listen, my wife's around here somewhere.
Face deep in a bowl of blue cheese and these losers circling
her like vultures Soon or later.
So mouse would try to get in her own business.
Now me.
I'm a proud Sigma Yeah, I'm an alpha man.
I don't care if my wife is getting banned by other men Snap
a pick of whoever she's mousing around with and we're golden
Yeah, that's definitely what a Sigma male would say.
Yeah.
I don't even know what your wife looks like.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Where is your wife?
Take a picture or refuse.
Yeah, what the fuck does your wife look like?
Why is a key?
Oh, she's over here.
Oh, sweet.
had this ship doesn't sink without me if it goes down i go
down with it we're divorce maxing right now hey guys um try
to figure out where the best place to take a i assume you
are the cheating wife right no oh all right i thought it'd
be you but i guess not where the fuck is the cheating way
between the out oh my god between an alpha and omega
under cover agent uh you press spot on good listen i'm under
cover of you we're building a case on sims but we need more
evidence you win what's the job simple Take some pictures.
You do carry a camera for a reason, right?
One might say that.
May apps?
Of some key BMP members.
Get close.
Snap a pick.
Bring them back to me.
I can do that.
Where do I start?
Oh, should I get extra money?
Exactly.
But they've been sniffing around the concert hall.
It shouldn't be too hard to spot.
Oh.
Okay.
maybe here you're not suspicious sir
are there any cheaters in the crowd oh right here okay not
the cheaters any any cheaters here anyone here's down to
cheat right now oh wait there's a way how do I get over
there
Not here.
You guys are just grooving right now.
But I know.
But I don't but I don't but I don't.
Let's just give the photo back.
Grab some money.
And hand over the photo.
Did you get it?
How do you do, fellow?
These will make a fine addition to our cheaters.
And to my promotion.
Here, your cut.
Wow.
What a score.
You know, it might even be enough for two pairs of socks.
I assume that's the bouncer.
Oh, this one would be where the cheaters are.
Oh, wait, no, that's the bouncer.
There were two footsteps.
I couldn't tell which one was the right one.
Oh, my God, it's right here.
This must be where the other footsteps taking me.
Oh, I didn't go up.
Wait, no, I did.
I'm so confused.
Where are you taking me?
Oh my god, right here.
Oh, it's back to the bouncer.
It's just everything leads back to him.
Unless...
Wait, wait, I'm gonna follow this.
surely it'll lead me somewhere else oh my god everything
just leads back to him
where is it going it all leads back to the bouncer
wait where did it go there he is oh my god i knew it we did
it we found him I knew he wasn't looping me.
I knew he knew where the cheaters are.
Okay, now I need to remember how to get back to the guy.
He goes like this way.
It's this way.
Where's the guy?
Oh, there's the Sigma.
Uh-huh.
Show me.
Figures, filthy trap.
She isn't going to cry.
Take this.
Just don't blow it all in one place.
Uh-huh.
I feel dirty.
Please don't make me do that again.
I was like a private investigator.
I feel like that's what most modern private investigators do
now.
They just find cheaters.
They're like, please, I think my husband is cheating on me.
Tell him.
I see who he's meeting up.
Oh my god, I need to remember where the bouncer is.
Oh, but um, but uh, okay.
Alright, this way.
Alright, we just wanted to check what they're doing.
You don't remember me, do you?
No, card please.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I see what you're doing.
Damn it.
It's stuck.
Guess there won't be no tax evasion can to blow in business
today.
So I just gotta kill me.
Alright, this way.
Just trying to see what they're up to, you know, for the
case, you know?
Just trying to do my job.
Guys, nothing else.
Nothing more.
Just doing my job.
I don't know.
But I don't.
I got another shortcut.
Am I supposed to go?
Oh, yep.
I got a key, though.
Wait, what key did I get?
Oh, this key.
Wait.
Guys, I didn't read.
Does anyone know what key I just got?
There were so many locked doors.
Oh, it was this key.
It's okay, I figured it out.
Oh.
Secret found.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff here.
All right, we got the storage.
Nice.
I think that's everything.
Oh my god, I thought I almost got stuck there.
Bum bum no.
No, where's the perfect spot for this sure there is the
perfect spot there's captain sims oh right here oh we grab
hp first just to be sure oh and arm him i wonder why i need
army i wonder why
shaking hands and rubbing shoulders the hell was that oh
yeah there's no back then there was always flash photography
well look who washed up i remember you pepper mpd's little
shoe shine star you you remember me that wasn't a compliment
now you haven't just ruined my day you've made a mess i'll
be cleaning up for weeks that won't do damn right it won't
because your little Trafficking sight hustle ends here,
Captain.
I'm burning it all down.
Good thing we're moored on the river.
Now, die.
Oh.
I guess it's not you.
Oh, shit.
I guess it is you.
I was gonna say I have reinforcements.
And I realized that was his reinforcements.
He has reinforcements.
JK, it was his reinforcements, not mine.
All right, let me grab this real quick.
Grab the acid.
Oh my god, they keep dodging.
Is that everybody?
Unfortunately, it's not.
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
There we go.
That should kill us.
Let's just survive.
You already said it was a shrew.
Oh, dog.
Dog time.
Okay, defeat Captain Sims.
Oh.
Well, what goes up?
Crash.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
All right.
I think that was him.
There we go.
We're done!
Nice.
Got him.
And again!
Where is he?
Oh, shit!
That's five.
Oh, shit.
I only have one shot.
There you go.
Got him?
Give me my heels here.
Gotta be careful.
I don't know if he does friendly five.
I gotta be careful.
Hey, nice.
Can you get me?
And another one.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, fuck.
Oh!
No!
Oh, oh, thank God.
The ocean's spitting.
me back out.
I wasn't tasty enough.
Oh, he shot the other cannon.
Just need one more.
Do I get rid of these guys, though?
Alright, wait until he finished shooting his misses.
Last shot!
That's right.
Get out!
out of here, Captain Sims.
You know, it'd be better if we kept you alive.
I think it'd be better if we kept this guy alive just so we
have evidence against him.
But alright.
Why is it that wherever I go, something ends up on fire?
I'm gonna say, shouldn't we be keeping them alive.
Need a hand?
Nah, man.
I'm done for.
Just leave me be.
Nah, it's just a scratch.
You're gonna be fine.
Nice one.
Just a little second half smoke.
Nothing to worry about.
Get to the wheelhouse.
There's an emergency inflatable plane there.
Emergency.
What now?
Playable play?
Okay.
I'm pretty much alive.
But okay.
I have to make sure.
You know, I got to watch to see if it does happen.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
I'm just cooking it.
It's acid time.
Boom.
But um bum
There's no way he lives that
Yeah, oh shit What about the I'm pretty sure they're five
I'm pretty sure they made it guys there it was the
inflatable plane Oh, there it is the deflated pilot a little
too trusting for his own good He's deaf shy couldn't die.
That's true.
You can't die when someone's watching him guys never meet
your heroes they say and sometimes they are dead right Sims
the shining star of the force turned out to be the
mastermind behind the crooked cops and the shrew kidnappings
he didn't just bite off more than he could chew he crossed
the mouse that once believed in him at least the shrews is
safe now as for my problems well nothing a glass or two of
john's best fondue can't smooth that seemed too easy there's
no way he was the mastermind
that seemed way too easy it's time it's time all the time i
don't see what wait you don't mean that's right time to
crack open the good stuff bud go with a bang cheese Furman
the oldest vintage you got tucked under there make it to on
my dad there's no way he was a mastermind of everything what
about the scientists I was starting to think this bottle
would outlive us both big day huh big enough John the
missing shrews case it's done turns out it was messier than
a trench coat and a cheeseburst crooked cops cheese leggers
offshore money a crime circus and now it is over or is it i
got them all john the redlining drones and the crooked queen
b and those shrews are heading home as we speak uh most of
them anyway we didn't really save the ones in the in the
crazy bin just uh thought you'd like to know uh-huh well oh
john knows all that lifted he's like are you sure don't get
me wrong that's good news great even warms the Maybe even
earns a headline or two.
But let's not kid ourselves.
It doesn't end here.
Give it a week, maybe a month, and someone else will start
clipping.
It's just how it is.
Always has been.
And until rodents like me can take a bus without getting
face planted in a rose bed simply for being short, it ain't
over.
Ah, your drink's salty enough without me raining on it.
You've done good, Jack.
real good it's just nah no john i get it it ain't the finish
line yeah there's more to be done if that one step gets you
closer to making shrew thicket a reality again then i'll
keep walking all right always one more job idiot making me
all misty whiskered to shrews john to shrew you can't fight
injustice That easily grab the quake case with corny and
john so sport Is it done?
Did we save the little guys?
Well, it's done and they're safe more or less and the
bastards behind it Did they finally get a slap from the
hired arm of justice?
Jack you you there buddy?
No corny.
I'm not there None of this is there.
Hell, none of this is even in the right country.
Chack?
It was Captain Goddamn Sims.
Him and his pack of crooked badges he either bought or
bullied into his operation.
The same Sims who was my shiny friggin North Star when I was
sweeping pavement as a beat cop.
Briefly anyway.
He wasn't just off course.
He built the course.
He was running this trafficking ring the whole time.
I didn't want to believe it, Corny.
damn well together to ignore you know what they say sport
never meet your heroes yeah well I didn't just meet him I
dragged his crooked keister and his fondude laundry all over
their fancy boat a few others got caught in the net before
the rest scattered like stale cheese crumbs but the shrews
are safe now right shouldn't that count for something yeah
sure i guess exactly someone else comes along thinking they
can make an easy buck off the little guy before they write
shrews out of their brave new world plans maybe you'd get it
if you talked to any of them i mean john's right there and
boy does he have stories i would jack but but but but you
know corny your heart's in the you'll miss what's right
under your snout from up there in your high perch you don't
see the grind the cracks that's right you're up in your high
horse down here it's real and it pities nobody you know why
i came to you with this in the first place because i'm dirt
cheap and too stubborn to quit no because between the two of
us you're the one who gets it Boots on the ground.
Eyes wide open.
You understand this world in ways I never will.
See, I'm for the people.
And I trust you.
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
So while you're busy taking this wicked machine apart piece
by piece, I can make sure it doesn't get rebuilt.
And with crooked cops out of the picture.
It wasn't just crooked cops.
Or cheese luggers for that matter.
exactly mice on one boat for it to be just the coincidence
there's something else here something bigger i knew it i
told you it wasn't there's no way i was like there's no way
he was the mastermind there was no way it was too easy that
has to be more than that back in the old world after we
dodged that shelling right before r and r no way it all
comes down from one very crooked
everything connects to each other he was just a cog in the
machine exactly I dragged him to up to my room switched our
clothes and sent him out the window when a commotion hit I
made for the fire escape yeah it was a rotten idea but what
was I supposed to do to have killed me and it was already
dead or grab a newspaper too main piece is a page report on
the mysterious moss man a towering creature is said to
occasionally emerge in the wetlands on the outskirts of
mouse bird it's just a folktale sponge but by some local is
indulgence cheese in the cheese of questionable quality or
is the moss man a real deal
oh new new quest any grand plans jack i don't know my
brain's running on fumes if this keeps up i might just check
myself into the loony bin good what what i ain't crazy you
know oh i know jack i know it's just that a um i heard from
a friend who heard from a friend that there's some asylum
for those impaired in some ways and apparently a lot of
celebs throw their wildest parties there what like some real
freak oh it's like a little freak circus the freak show
proof that's where you come in tammy Oh my god, it's like
those who are so rich that they just do crazy shit Before
the island we had we had If you ever make it there, snap a
photo and bring it to me I'll whip up something extra in
return Deal Yeah, sure Alright, let's see I wanna save up
for the I'll save up for the pistol I'll save up for the
pistol all right let's see pin your remaining sure all right
let's pin the remaining clues
all right my last clue i'll need more proof to be sure you
weren't even sure and then you fucking said we got him boys
why do you mean we need more proof i thought i told you he
was like we did it guys we solved the case anyway i think we
need more clues before we actually call them guilty.
This is why you're cheap, Jack.
This is why.
Anyway, we're gonna call it here.
There are.
There's still a lot of levels left.
We have eight more levels to go.
So I'm pretty sure we can finish, uh, P.I.
Mouse P.I.
in two, wait, it was, it was in two days?
Uh, on the next stream.
Hey guys, that's fun.
I don't know.
The movement in this game is really fun.
I love, like, I figure out the movement tech for it where
it's like it's like jump jump slide jump jump slide.
It's really fun Anyway, great fun fun game as always.
I've been enjoying mass PI a lot I've been enjoying the
shooting and also the movement for this game and yeah, the
story is very interesting It's all coming together every all
the all the pieces all the clues is all coming together
right now We're almost done with the clue boy Anyway guys,
I'm gonna call here got work on some stuff behind the scenes
but i always enjoy streaming for you guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flow and if you suffer me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye